Leute, mein Sound stimmt nicht.
Warum ist die Musik raus?
Wo ist die Musik rausgegangen?
Die hängt einfach.
Keck, wait, Alter.
Was ist da los?
Oh, die Emotes sind ein bisschen groß.
Mein Sound ist kaputt.
Ich weiß, Moment, Moment.
Das muss man kurz mal fixen.
Weil Teams gerne am Sound rumstehen.
Nee, ist gar nicht kaputt.
Eifhäder.
Ich muss berufstechnisch drum kümmern, aber es ist echt der Wahnsinn, wenn die Scheiße nicht funktioniert, wie sie funktionieren soll.
Mein Raspberry Pi im Wohnzimmer kackt immer ab.
Ich bin jetzt dahinter gekommen, woran das liegt.
Wahrscheinlich, weil die SSD zu viel Strom verbraucht.
Ja, naja, was willst du machen?
Der Kram muss halt funktionieren.
Wahrscheinlich, weil die SSD zu viel Strom verbraucht in Kombination mit dem TV-Tuner.
Ich bin mir auch nicht mal so sicher.
Ob das so eine gute Idee ist, dass ich im Wohnzimmer einen Raspberry Pi mit einem USB-Tuner für Fernsehen gucke.
Also, ich gucke ja keinen Fernsehen, aber ich bin ja leider nicht der Einzige hier.
Was das angeht.
Ich habe da Leute, die gerne Fernsehen gucken.
Ich verstehe es nicht, aber okay.
Soll jeder machen, was er will.
Also, im wörtlichen Sinne.
Vielleicht.
Wobei das den ganzen Tag über funktioniert.
Also, ich hätte gar nicht gedacht, dass das so eine gute Idee ist.
Ich hätte ganz schön Probleme, wenn das nur morgens klappen würde.
Weiß nicht.
Wäre ungesund.
Meine Mutter ist 72.
Die guckt Fernsehen.
Also, du hast prinzipiell recht.
Aber wobei, gibt bestimmt genug.
Die ist 72.
Die guckt jeden Tag Fernsehen.
Die guckt auch so komisches Zeug wie Tatort und sowas.
Und das Problem ist halt, es ist alles Müll.
Die Fernsehtechnik ist einfach.
Müll.
Du kannst.
Über den Fernseher gucken, dann bräuchtest du, dass du alles gucken kannst.
So eine komische Smartcard von Vodafone, wo sie dir verbieten können, das Fernsehprogramm aufzunehmen, zu spulen oder Timeshift zu machen.
Das ist Gängelung für das, was ich bezahlen soll.
Also, ich bezahle und werde dafür gegängelt.
Das muss man sich mal vorstellen.
Das ist so weirdchamp.
Das Leute.
Ich weiß nicht, was sie überhaupt machen.
Bleibt halt zur Auswahl freiempfangbare Programme.
Aber aufnehmen auf dem Fernseher kann ich nicht gescheit, weil das Vendor-Login ist und du kannst nirgendwo anders dranhängen, sollte mal ich den Fernseher wechseln oder so.
BESCHEUERD.
Also im Endeffekt bleibt mir nur übrig, Aufnahme zu machen über einen Raspberry Pi mit USB-Tuner.
Keine privaten Programme in HD zu gucken.
Und nur so kann ich halt alles machen, was ich machen will.
Aber das geht mir auf den Keks.
Weil das irgendwie sehr anstrengend ist.
Das gibt bestimmt, was weiß ich, einmal in der Woche vielleicht irgendwie den Geist auf.
Und ich weiß nicht, woran das liegt.
Ich vermute am Stromverbrauch vom Raspberry Pi.
Also richtig Painschamp.
Hat jemand von euch mal sowas hier ausprobiert?
Ähm.
Hat jemand mal solche Kisten ausprobiert?
Habt ihr mal sowas ausprobiert?
Also ich will die nicht haben.
Ähm.
Weil ich damit auf dem Fernseher bin.
Weil ich damit auf dem Fernseher gucken will.
Sondern weil die Tuner wohl ganz gut sind.
Du hast eine UNO 4K.
Okay.
Ähm.
Das ist gut, dass du eine hast.
Da muss ich dich gleich mal was fragen.
Welches Image hast du dafür?
Und ähm.
Also ich hab mir das so gedacht, man könnte das Ding als Tuner verwenden und als Aufnahmebox.
Und gucken würde ich weiterhin mit Kodio auf dem Shield TV.
VTE-Image.
Okay.
Hast du...
Holst du den EPG?
Holst du den EPG aus dem...
Achso.
Was sagst du?
DVB-C?
DVB-S?
Also Satellit?
Und holst du den EPG übers Internet?
Oder holst du den EPG aus dem Stream vom Anbieter?
Moin.
Danke für den Sub übrigens.
Irgendwas hab ich hier vergessen, Freund.
Stubenhocker.
POG.
Also quasi.
Ich bin mit dieser Aussprache so weggeblieben, Alter.
POG.
Ja, das stimmt.
Das ist richtig.
Das Problem ist nicht...
In dem Fall nicht das Raspberry Pi Netzteil, sondern dass die USB-SSD so viel Strom braucht,
mehr als die USB-Ports liefern können.
Ich hab's jetzt schon probiert mit einem USB-Hub, aber das ist auch Müll.
Das ist richtig riesiges Kabelgedöns und funktioniert auch nicht richtig.
DVB-C Vodafone.
Nice.
Okay.
Das wäre das gleiche Setup bei mir.
Funktioniert das mit dem EPG?
Hast du Genre und Titel und Serientitel und sowas drinnen?
Weil da hatte ich bei TV-Headend richtig Probleme, dass das Genre aus dem EPG funktioniert
bei mir bis heute nicht richtig mit TV-Headend.
Ich meine nicht, dass das Genre jetzt irgendwie großartig wichtig wäre bei Fernsehsendungen.
Ich meine, du guckst eher nach dem Titel, aber es wäre schon nice, weil daraufhin kann
Kodi nämlich den EPG entsprechend einfärben.
Also...
Ja.
Das würde mich echt interessieren, ob du alle Daten aus dem...
Aus dem EPG bekommst, die man haben will, so.
Naja.
Also, wie gesagt, ich weiß nicht, ob sich das lohnt.
Ich würde damit nicht Fernsehen gucken.
Ich würde es nur als Aufnahme-Box und Streaming-Box verwenden, aber wahrscheinlich funktioniert
es besser als ein Raspberry Pi mit USB-Tuner.
Theoretisch hätte man die Option, wenn man eine Vodafone-Smartcard hat, da auch mit so
halblegalen Mitteln private Programme in HD zu entschlüsseln und dann ohne Restriktionen,
aber da habe ich gar keinen Bock drauf.
Ah ja.
Mal gucken.
Können wir uns theoretisch im Stream angucken?
Ne, dann ist wahrscheinlich, dann ist wahrscheinlich...
Ja, also normalerweise wird DVB-C oder über das DVB-Signal wird normalerweise ausgestrahlt,
ob eine Sendung, keine Ahnung, ein Spielfilm ist, eine Serie ist, Drama ist, Comedy ist
oder sowas.
Und wenn das, wenn das der EPG erfasst, dann kann Kodi das EPG entsprechend einfärben.
Ist aber jetzt nicht so wild.
Guckst du auch direkt darüber Fernsehen vorm Tapes?
Oder streamst du das dann von da auf eine andere Box?
Also ich bleibe auf jeden Fall bei meinem Shield TV, Android TV als Frontend einfach
wegen den ganzen Apps drauf, weil nur so kannst du von Netflix bis Prime Video bis YouTube
und so alles gucken.
Das geht ja über das Teil sonst gar nicht richtig.
Ja, der, der, der EPG funktioniert bei mir auch, nur macht der EPG öfters mal Probleme.
Manchmal fehlen Senderkomponenten.
Also ich habe, das hat, TV-Headern hatte bei mir schon immer Probleme mit dem EPG.
Das kann aber auch an meinem USB-Tuner liegen.
Es ist, ist durchaus möglich.
Ähm, manchmal, manchmal gehen manche Sender nicht für ein paar Tage.
Die sind dann einfach leer.
Warum auch immer.
Dann erholt sich das Ganze wieder.
Ähm, ah, okay.
Äh, die, die, wie gesagt, das Genre grabben funktioniert teilweise nicht.
Es ist, es ist merkwürdig.
Aber ich meine, es ist brauchbar.
Es ist in Ordnung.
Kann man, kann man benutzen.
Ja.
Viel eher, viel mehr Probleme habe ich, dass der Raspberry Pi ab und zu abkackt und es
dann nicht funktioniert.
Und ich hasse es, wenn Technik nicht funktioniert, in dem Sinn, wenn ich dann um Support gefragt
werde, ja, und wenn die drüben sitzen oder drüben sitzt im Wohnzimmer und das nicht geht
und ich dann genervt werde mit, hier, guck mal, der Fernseher geht nicht, das fuckt mich
ab.
Ich will irgendwas, was, was einmal aufgesetzt wird, dann deaktiviere ich Updates und dann
funktioniert es einfach.
Scheiß auf Updates.
Wenn es dazu führt, dass es kaputt geht, ist mir doch wurscht.
Das Ding soll einfach nur Fernsehanzeigen.
Gut ist.
Shield TV hat Updates aus.
Android Apps haben Updates aus.
Kodi Plugins haben Updates aus.
Alles Updates aus.
Das ist ein Setup, was funktioniert.
Ich mache da keine automatischen Updates, kriege eine neue Kodi-Version und der Kram funktioniert
nicht mehr.
Ganz bestimmt nicht.
Das mache ich höchstens, wenn es Probleme gibt, update ich mal alles.
Moin Wolle.
Danke für den Sub.
Huge Subscription.
Ich brauche neue Kekse.
Die sind fast, die meisten Leute, die lange dabei sind, haben schon alle die Kekse, die
sie haben.
Die sind fast, die meisten Leute, die lange dabei sind, haben schon alle die Kekse.
Gibt es nicht schon so ein Intel NUC mit Kabelanschluss?
Nö.
Es gibt diese Dinger.
Wie gesagt, es gibt diese Dinger an Boxen.
Die haben dann auch ein, ein, ein Oktotuner oder so drin.
Da kannst du irgendwie acht Sachen gleichzeitig empfangen.
für so ziemlich alles im Haushalt reichen.
Ich will mich demnächst für ein duales Studium Wirtschaftsinformatik bei einer Bank
in der Nähe von Frankfurt, weil es schwer ist, da so einen Platz ranzukommen.
Ganz ehrlich, aktuell ist es, also okay, ich habe keine Erfahrung, was duales Studium angeht.
Also es kann sein, dass ich jetzt komplett falsch liege,
aber allgemein ist es relativ easy, aktuell in der IT irgendwelche Jobs zu bekommen.
Ich weiß nicht, wie es als dualer Student aussieht.
Aber für die Azubis ist es gerade gut, für ausgelernte Leute,
für studierte Leute eh, generell Jobs in der IT sind zur Zeit easy.
Was aber witzig ist, das ist so die Branche, die geht da auch komplett gegen den Trend.
Überall anders werden Stellen abgebaut, weil die ersetzt werden durch,
was weiß ich, AI, Roboter, Automatisierung, Optimierung, Outsourcing, was auch immer.
Und in der IT brauchst du halt immer mehr Leute.
Aber das gleicht trotzdem nicht aus, auf Dauer, denke ich mal.
Was ich aber witzig finde, Leute, eine Sache.
Ich glaube, eine Sache, die man die letzten Jahre über schon gelernt hat
und spätestens jetzt, seit dieser Krise da in Russland oder mit Russland und allem,
ich glaube, dass die ganze Outsourcing-Geschichte ein bisschen zurückgefahren wird.
Weil man hat jetzt gesehen, dass es ziemlich doof ist,
sich von Russen oder China-Chinesen abhängig zu machen.
Gerade bei den Chinesen, die einfach mal keine Schiffe nach Shanghai reingelassen haben.
Ähm, tja.
Ich glaube, das wird auch Auswirkungen darauf haben, dass die Leute sagen,
okay, wir lassen es mal mit Outsourcing ein bisschen bleiben.
Mal gucken.
Bin mal gespannt, was da rauskommt.
Meine Stonks sind immer noch im Keller.
Aber das macht nichts.
Es ist eh nur ein World-ETF.
Das geht auch wieder hoch.
Könnte jetzt eigentlich nochmal ein bisschen was kaufen.
Na gut.
Was der Raspberry Pi von einem Freund hat auch zicken gemacht, weil er an einem...
Ja, ja, wie gesagt, ich hab das auch...
Das ist nicht das Problem.
Die SSD verbraucht zu viel Strom.
Wenn ich...
Das merke ich auch daran.
Normalerweise ist das kein Ding.
Der Raspberry Pi, der taktet sich runter, wenn er selbst zu wenig Strom hat.
Aber ich sehe es ja auch im Log.
Die SSD kackt ab.
Und...
Ich kann das auch nachstellen.
Wenn ich die SSD an USB 2 anschließe, ist überhaupt kein Problem.
Aber sobald ich dann USB 3 anschließe und die auch ein bisschen Strom zieht, weil sie ordentlich Übertragungsrate hat,
kackt die mir ab.
Ich mache entweder eine andere SSD dran.
Oder...
Ich schmeiße den Raspberry Pi komplett weg und kaufe mir vielleicht doch irgendwie sowas.
Als Streaming-Box.
Beziehungsweise halt rein als Fernseh-Box.
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Space-Musik.
Ich versuche gerade mit Websockets eine Webseite asynchron vom Server aus abzudehnen.
Ist dabei...
Ja.
Websocket ist das einzige, was du nehmen kannst.
Sind voll.
Es gibt noch verschiedene Wrapper.
Du kannst Signal A nehmen oder sowas.
Das ist im Prinzip auch nur ein Wrapper, um sowas in der Richtung...
Und um Legacy-Browser zu unterstützen.
Dir bleibt dir nichts anderes übrig, außer Websockets zu nehmen.
Äh, mittlerweile...
Wobei, das stimmt nicht so ganz.
Mittlerweile kann man...
Man kann auch gRPC über HTTP machen.
Und...
Du kannst CraftQL-Subscriptions verwenden.
Aber CraftQL-Subscriptions sind im Endeffekt auch Websockets.
Also eigentlich gibt es nur Websockets.
Du kannst natürlich auch...
Die Easy-Variante, die tatsächlich gar nicht so schlecht ist.
Du kannst auch einfach periodisch abfragen.
Du kannst auch einfach alle 50 Sekunden abfragen.
Je nachdem, wie viel Daten das sind.
Dann mag das gar nicht so schlecht sein.
Ja.
Bisschen laut.
Hab auf Reddit von jemand gelesen,
der drei Internetverbindungen mit Loadbalancer privat hat,
damit er Ruhe hat, dass das Internet nicht geht.
Okay, dann würde ich mal über einen neuen Provider nachdenken.
Also, ich meine, ich bin mit Vodafone jetzt ja auch nicht so super glücklich.
Aber...
Da hätte ich echt...
Würde ich mir Gedanken machen, wenn ich drei Internetverbindungen...
Also ich hatte ja früher genau für diesen Fall auch zwei Internetverbindungen.
Ich hatte ja noch Backup, Telekom-Leitung und Vodafone.
Aber man muss sagen, das hat sich gelohnt.
Ich habe den Kram ja abbestellt.
Das war einfach unsinnig Geld.
Ich habe es eh kaum...
Ich habe es eh kaum verwendet.
Und...
Die Vodafone-Geschichte ist so weit ganz okay.
Relativ in Ordnung, ja.
Ich überlege gerade, ob ich auch Vodafone Business upgrade.
Ich habe die auch am Freitag oder Donnerstag irgendwann mal angeschrieben auf Twitter.
Und da meinen sie, ja, wir beantworten dir alle Fragen.
Da habe ich ihnen die Fragen geschickt.
Da haben sie gesagt, nein, Business-Fragen beantworten wir nicht.
Also, ja, okay.
Dann wollte ich den Business-Account auf Twitter anschreiben.
Und die wollen nicht auf Twitter.
Die muss man anrufen.
Da sieht man halt, das ist Boomer-Business-Zeug.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ich da Bock drauf habe.
Ich meine, warum soll ich mit echten Menschen kommunizieren und reden am Telefon,
wenn ich das auch schreiben könnte über Twitter?
Verstehe ich nicht.
Ja.
Könnte man machen.
Dazu brauche ich erstmal eine Fritzbox-Cable.
Ich habe keine Fritzbox-Cable und eine Fritzbox...
Was kosten die aktuell?
Cable Fritz...
Fritzbox.
Fritz...
Fritzboxes mit Cable.
Da.
So.
Braucht das alles nicht?
Was ist das für eine komische Benahmung, Alter?
Ich brauche kein WiFi da drinnen.
Ich brauche nichts.
Ich brauche einfach nur Tuner.
Haben die alle Tuner?
Wo sieht man denn, was die für Tuner haben?
Steht gar nicht dabei, oder?
Oder haben die alle?
Okay, gucken wir mal. Amazon.
Ich weiß aber nicht, ob Unity...
Wo davon Business macht.
Boah, ist aber auch nicht gerade billig.
Wobei es geht.
Es gibt für andere Sachen mehr unsinnig Geld aus.
Das ist ein Vierer.
Der Vierer zieht eh schon mehr Strom.
Aber das kommt auf die SSD an.
Also das ist bekannt.
Wenn man im Internet danach sucht.
Der Raspberry Pi hat Probleme.
Oder was heißt Probleme?
Weiß gar nicht, ob es am Raspberry Pi liegt.
Der hat Limitierungen, was Stromverbrauch über den USB angeht.
Und wenn du eine SSD hast, die in Spitzenzeiten quasi mehr verbraucht, dann kackt es ab.
Naja, alle Millisekunden nicht.
Aber alle Millisekunden ist mit Websocket vielleicht auch etwas Hardcore.
Also ganz ehrlich, weißt du, was ich machen würde, wenn ich alle Millisekunden was zum Updaten habe, hätte?
Ich würde weder Websockets nehmen, noch sonst was.
Ich würde irgendeinen konstanten Stream nehmen vom Server zum Client aus.
Irgendeinen Streaming-Kram, der einfach nicht aufhört.
Du brauchst ja hier gar nichts Asynchrones.
Man kann ja bei einer Millisekunde nicht wirklich von Asynchronen benachrichtigen sprechen.
Wenn das eh alle Millisekunden kommt.
Dann würde ich einfach irgendeinen Stream aufmachen, der permanent liest.
Hattest du mal ein Kabel?
Ich habe immer noch einen Kabelanschluss.
Moin.
Schwulius Cäsar.
Kappa Pride.
Ja doch, ich habe immer noch einen Kabelanschluss.
Habe ich, ja.
Übrigens Leute, ich habe die 5-Headingster Heimautomatisierungsidee gesehen, seit langer Zeit gestern.
In einem Forum.
Und zwar, ja.
Der Typ hat, der Typ, Alter was macht der?
Der Darkreader.
Der Typ hat sich einen Regensensor gebaut.
Und zwar, jetzt haltet euch fest, mit einem Wasserleaksensor.
Aber anders als man eigentlich so denkt.
Also, die Dinger sehen so aus.
Das ist Zigbee.
Das ist dieses Xiaomi-Akara-Zeug.
Die Dinger sehen so aus und die haben unten zwei Kontakte.
Und die Idee von diesen Sensoren ist, die legst du hier hin auf diese Kontakte.
Und wenn die, wenn es unten drunter nass wird, dann leitet es zwischen den beiden Kontakten und das Ding meldet, dass irgendwo Wasser ausläuft.
Aber, der hier ist auf die clevere Idee gekommen, sich ein Regensensorboard zu nehmen und das anzulöten unten dran.
Also die Kontakte werden nicht verwendet, um hier quasi per Kurzschluss zu erkennen, ob der Untergrund nass ist.
Sondern, die werden quasi als Sensoreingang.
Verwendet für diesen Regensensorboard, für dieses Regensensorboard.
Also das ist wirklich massive Feifheit.
Auf die Idee wäre ich gar nicht gekommen.
Wobei das theoretisch mit jedem x-beliebigen Sensor funktioniert, wo du halt Binary-Sensor-Sachen anschließen kannst.
Aber das fand ich sehr feifheitig.
Die Sache ist nur die, ich werde es nicht bauen, weil diese Regensensorboards richtig beschissen sind.
Die, die rosten und, und gingen kaputt.
Nach 2-3 Jahren draußen.
Also eigentlich komplett sinnlos.
Aber die Idee fand ich, fand ich massive Feifheit.
Ich habe mir auch schon überlegt.
Leute, kennt jemand irgendeine gute Wetterstation?
Z-Wave, Zigbee, WLAN.
Oder meinetwegen auch 433 MHz Funk, die man gescheit in Home Assistant einbinden kann.
Weil, was mir jetzt schon öfters aufgefallen ist, dass die ganzen Outdoor-Temperatursensoren nicht so gut...
Also das ist eine davon.
Nicht so hundertprozentig genau sind.
Und, dass es relativ praktisch ist, wenn man weiß, ob es geregnet hat in letzter Zeit, ob es gerade regnet.
Man sieht ja auch kleine Regen, nicht unbedingt immer.
Ja, wie Sonneneinfall am Tag war, wie der Wind so ist.
Da weiß man beispielsweise schon gleich morgens, was man anziehen muss.
Ich meine, alternativ ist, man könnte einfach mal kurz im Unterhemd vor die Tür gehen.
Und dann gucken, was man anzieht.
Aber, ich meine, warum sollte ich im Unterhemd vor die Tür gehen, wenn ich auch eine WLAN-Wetterstation bei mir an die Wand hängen kann?
Ja, logisch, oder?
Sag mal, Chat, sagt gerade keiner was?
Oder ist der Chat kaputt?
Muss ich gerade mal testen.
Keck, wait.
Ne, ich glaube, es sagt bloß einfach keiner was.
Nice.
Chat, Chat, nicht Walkge, Chat.
Wettge.
Hab diese direkt in HA integriert, funktioniert mega.
Waldbeck Hailey Profi Wetterstation, 6 in 1 Messung auf einen Blick.
Das ist doch ein China-Chinesen-Ding, oder?
Der Name von diesem Ding ist schon wieder...
Ja, das ist garantiert Waldbeck.
Das ist doch...
Es klingt nicht China-Chinesen, aber es ist bestimmt China-Chinesen-Zeug.
Die haben es deutsch benannt, weil die denken, das ist...
Das muss ich mir jetzt mal gucken, ob das wirklich China-Chinesen-Zeug ist oder nicht.
Ja, es ist China-Chinesen-Zeug.
Ja, sonst hätten die eine deutsche Webseite.
Waldbeck.
Irgendeiner in China ist auf einen deutschen Markennamen-Generator gekommen und da ist dann Waldbeck rausgekommen.
Das soll quasi nach deutschem Hersteller klingen, ist es aber nicht.
Das ist wahrscheinlich China-Chinesen-Gramm.
Sieht man auch an diesen AliExpress-Bildern schon.
Die sind schlau, oder?
Also eins muss man den Chinesen lassen.
In der Richtung sind die wirklich business-stocks-technisch ganz vorne mit dabei.
Ecovit.
Kenn ich nicht. Ecovit.
Das ist aber bestimmt irgendwas mit Cloud, das will ich nicht.
So, das Ding hast du integriert, okay.
Lässt sich das...
Wie lässt sich das integrieren?
Wie integriert man das in Home Assistant?
Kann das Ding direkt MQTT? Das glaube ich kaum.
Was braucht man dafür?
By the way, die Fernbedienung sieht fast 1 zu 1 so aus wie die Fernbedienung für meine Klimaanlage.
Naja gut, außer diesen Löcher hier.
Das Ding sieht schon ein bisschen hardcore-billig aus.
Moment, ist das einfach eine stinknormale 433 MHz Funkanlage und man braucht einfach einen Empfänger dafür?
Such mal Ecovits Hax.
Was da?
Wetterstation.
Ecovit Weather Station Integration for Home Assistant, okay.
Ah, das ist cool.
Und die geht damit?
Ja, die Dark Sky RP, die habe ich auch.
Und das geht damit, oder wie?
Das wäre natürlich äußerst 5 Header.
Das, oh man, Leute, da muss jetzt irgendwie einer ankommen wieder.
Nein, nein, China produziert heißt nicht automatisch schlecht.
Deutsche Produkte werden auch in China produziert.
Das ist richtig, deutsche Produkte werden in China produziert.
Aber, die haben nicht zu, wie soll ich sagen, die haben nicht zu Unrecht diesen Ruf weg,
dass das Standard China-Chinesen-Produkt vielleicht jetzt qualitativ etwas zu wünschen übrig lässt.
Das ist immer noch so.
Die produzieren gute Sachen, beispielsweise Staubsaugerroboter.
Aber man sieht den Unterschied auch bei Staubsaugerrobotern.
Wenn man mal so einen Xiaomi-Staubsaugerroboter aufmacht oder irgendeinen aus den USA oder in Deutschland entworfenen,
muss ja nicht mal ein Deutschlandproduzierter sein,
da siehst du gleich den Unterschied, was für uns gut ist,
weil die meisten China-Chinesen-Geräte total easy zu modden sind.
Die legen beispielsweise keinen Wert darauf, dass das ordentlich implementiert ist,
was WiFi, Security oder sonst was angeht.
Du kannst Dinger teilweise aus China OTA flashen, die nicht OTA geflasht werden sollen.
Du hast Rootkeys im Internet, wo du dich auf jedem Gerät einloggen kannst und sowas in der Richtung.
Für uns ist das gut, die modden wollen.
Insgesamt spricht es aber schon dafür, dass man dort, naja, gerade was Build-Quality und Security angeht,
oftmals nicht so der Sache den Stellenwert beimisst, den man sich vielleicht wünschen würde.
Und die meisten Sachen, die du auf AliExpress billig kriegst, sind nicht umsonst billig.
Das muss man sich ja auch mal sehen, äh, das muss man sich ja auch mal vor Augen halten.
Der Kram ist ja nicht umsonst billig.
DVB-T-Stick?
Also ich hab, ich hab nen Empfänger für 433 MHz, das sollte doch eigentlich reichen, oder?
Also das heißt, du kannst, nur dass ich das immer richtig verstehe,
du kannst dieses Ding hier nehmen, dann per USB anschließen an dein Home Automation Rechner
und das dann einrichten in Home Automation.
Äh, Home Assistant mit dieser Integration, oder wie?
Das ist ja mal 5 Header hochzählen, das find ich geil.
Das mach ich, glaub ich.
Das wird, das wird geordert dann, wenn das, wenn, also wenn das so geht, wenn...
Ah, über WLAN.
Über WLAN?
Wie jetzt?
Warum brauch ich diesen Empfänger dann noch, wenn, wenn ich WLAN mache?
Was?
Versteh ich nicht.
Ist das hier nicht USB angeschlossen?
Weil die ist doch nicht WLAN, oder?
WLAN fähig.
Das müsstest du mir nochmal...
Funktioniert nicht im WLAN.
Ach, Moment!
Die Station wird mit Batterien versorgt?
Ne.
Kann ich, kann ich die nicht anschließen an irgendein Kabel?
Ich will die nicht mit Batterien versorgen.
Kann man die nicht?
Ha.
Das hält doch nicht, das hält doch dann wieder nur ein halbes Jahr.
Wenn man die, wenn man die versorgt mit, mit Batterien.
Ne, das ist doof.
Also mir wär, mir wär das mit nem ordentlichen Kabel schon lieber, weil...
Genau an der Ecke, wo ich das, wo ich das positionieren würde...
Ähm...
Hab ich nämlich auch ein Stromkabel.
Was sehr...
POG-G ist.
Naja.
Aber ich brauch kein Def...
Also wie gesagt, ich muss das, sowas nicht über...
Achso!
Okay, das ist natürlich auch cool.
Okay, also dass ich das, dass ich das richtig verstehe.
Was man machen muss, ist...
Man hängt die Wetterstation draußen irgendwo hin, macht Batterien rein.
Dann nimmt man diese Basisstation hier.
Und dann...
Wo schließt man...
Diese Basisstation, das hier ist nur ein Stromkabel, oder was?
Und die Basisstation hänge ich dann ins WLAN.
Also die Basisstation kommt ins WLAN.
Und...
Das kann ich dann mit der Integration in Home Assistant einrichten.
Warum...
Kann man nicht direkt das RF-Signal abgreifen?
Und braucht dieses Zwischending hier nicht?
Das finde ich aber gut.
Das überlege ich mir tatsächlich.
Ja, das ist die...
Die Anzeige brauche ich nicht.
Die kommt bei mir dann aufs Tablet.
Und wie genau ist das?
Kann man auch so...
Ja, ich habe einen 433 MHz Empfänger dran für meine Rollladen.
Ist das überhaupt die Eco-Witch dazu?
Anscheinend nicht, aber anscheinend kompatibel dazu.
Sagt zumindest der Chat.
Ähm...
Internet connected?
Wie jetzt?
Ja, wahrscheinlich nur mit der Cloud.
Das probiere ich aus.
Sehr guter Tipp.
Wenn der Chat sagt, dass das funktioniert, dann probiere ich das.
Der Chat ist ja prinzipiell eigentlich immer richtig.
Der ideale Begleiter für alle Wetterfrisch...
Oh nein, Leute!
Ich wurde geflamed von Jörg Kachelmann auf Twitter, Leute.
Wo ich das gerade lese.
Ich benutze die falsche Wetterseite.
Hat er mir gesagt.
Ich soll kachelmannwetter.de verwenden.
Ich habe mich beschwert auf Twitter.
Ich habe mich beschwert auf Twitter, dass die Wettervorhersage in letzter Zeit so schlecht ist.
Ähm...
Ich habe geschrieben, warum ist die Wettervorhersage in letzter Zeit so schlecht?
Haben die Hardware downgraded?
Gestern hieß es noch 10 Stunden Sonne.
Und irgendwann antwortet...
Alter Twitter!
Geh mal nicht auf den Sack, Mann.
Ich will doch einfach nur...
No!
No, God, please, no!
Guck!
Ich wurde von Jörg Kachelmann persönlich geflamed, dass ich nicht die richtige Wetterseite verwende.
Ich soll gefälligst kachelmannwetter.com verwenden.
Tja, da muss ich das wohl machen.
Die deutsche Wetterdienst-App, die habe ich auch auf dem Handy.
Das ist die App, die sie nicht mehr kostenlos anbieten durften, weil sie zu gut war.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das kennt, Leute.
Das ist richtig hängen geblieben.
Der deutsche Wetterdienst hatte mal eine Wetter-App, die nannte sich Warnwetter.
Das ist dafür da...
Das ist dafür da gewesen, ursprünglich mal um...
Über...
Doch, das ist sein Ernst.
Überschwemmungen, Unwetter und so zu warnen.
Die haben die dann aber mit der Zeit ausgebaut, dass du im Prinzip die beste Wetter-App, die es gab, hattest.
Du hattest alles drin, ja.
Zig verschiedene Screens, Wind, Regen, Wolken, auf welcher Höhe, sonst wie.
Das war die beste Wetter-App, die es gab.
Und die war halt...
Weil es quasi, wie soll man sagen, eh schon steuerfinanziert ist irgendwie, war die kostenlos.
Das heißt, diese Warnwetter-App vom deutschen Wetterdienst war die beste Wetter-App kostenlos.
Und irgendwann hat Wetter.com geklagt dagegen, dass das für den...
Dass das irgendwie wettbewerbsbeeinträchtigend wäre, wenn die beste Wetter-App kostenlos angeboten wird.
Weil, was sollen sie denn da machen?
Und daraufhin hat ein Gericht entschieden, dass diese App nicht mehr kostenlos angeboten werden darf.
Nur noch die Basisversion, um Wetterwarnungen rauszusenden.
Also das muss man sich mal überlegen.
Die beste Wetter-App war kostenlos und irgendein Gericht hat gesagt, die darf nicht mehr kostenlos sein.
Das ist doch nicht vermittelbar an die Leute, oder?
Das heißt, der deutsche Wetterdienst macht die gleichen Sachen wie vorher von meinen Steuern, was okay ist.
Und sie hätten es kostenlos angeboten.
Jetzt kriegen sie halt nochmal extra Geld.
Ganz ehrlich, ich kaufe mir die auch, die deutsche Wetterdienst-App.
Ist kein Problem, kostet irgendwie 2,30 oder so.
Weiß ich gar nicht, ob die...
DVD-Warnwetter.
Genau, das ist die kostenlose, glaube ich.
So, das ist die kostenlose.
Die hat jetzt nur noch Basic-Funktion und die neue, die...
Oder vielleicht hat die auch mittlerweile intern was zum Kaufen.
Zumindest die Standard-Version ist jetzt nur noch...
Also die standardkostenpflichtige Version ist jetzt nur noch eingeschränkt.
Es ist total hängengeblieben, das muss man sich echt mal vorstellen.
Die bieten kostenlos eine bessere Wetter-App an, als die, die bezahlt wird.
So.
Easy-Wettbewerb.
Geht nicht.
Muss auch was kosten.
Okay, Leute.
Was können wir uns denn heute mal anschauen?
Zeigt mal ja.
Interview mit einem Agil-Coach.
Oh ne, das fand ich letztes Mal schon nicht lustig.
Wir sind viel zu agil, um uns coachen zu lassen in Agilness.
Wir leben agil.
Wir sind agil.
Da brauchen wir keine Coaches für.
Der Chat ist eh der agilste Chat auf der Welt.
Wir machen nicht Daily-Stand-Up.
Wir machen minütliches Stand-Up hier.
Wir stehen quasi nur noch.
Ganz ehrlich, da kommt bestimmt auch noch demnächst irgendwie einer der Manager-Leute drauf.
Daily-Stand-Up ist zu wenig.
Wir brauchen jetzt stündliches...
Das darf nicht Stand-Up heißen.
Das braucht dann irgendwie was anderes.
Stündlicher Austausch oder sowas.
Stündliches Update-Stand-Up oder sowas.
Wobei, das gibt es wahrscheinlich schon.
Sonst ist man nicht agil genug.
Wie geht es der Katz?
Tja, weiß ich nicht, wo die gerade rumeiert.
Wahrscheinlich irgendwo.
Ich habe hier die Tür zu.
Vielleicht legt sie irgendwo rum.
Der 34234-Fernsehtyp hat ein neues Video.
Ja, das habe ich schon aufgemacht.
Irgendwas mit 3D-Drucker.
So, was verdient ein Rohrleitungsbauer?
Ein bisschen sieht der Typ aus wie Superman, oder?
So ganz leicht auf den ersten Blick.
Oder wie Geralt.
Oder was hat er denn sonst noch gespielt?
Ehrlich gesagt, fangen wir bloß die zwei Sachen ein.
Was hat er denn sonst noch gemacht?
Der hat bestimmt total viele Filme mitgespielt.
Ey, bei Mission Impossible war er glaube ich auch mit am Start irgendwann.
Ähm...
Keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß...
Wie heißt denn der Actor überhaupt?
Henry Cavill, glaube ich.
Ja.
Was hat er denn sonst noch gemacht?
Mir fällt eigentlich nur ein Witcher und Superman.
Und wie gesagt, ich glaube bei irgendeiner Mission Impossible...
...Teil 75 oder so...
...war er auch dabei.
Ach, keine Ahnung. Interessiert mich auch nicht.
Wie würdest du eigentlich ein Raspberry Pi mit SSD betreiben?
Mit Festplatte schon mal gar nicht, mit SSD.
Äh...
USB auf SATA?
Oder eine USB-SSD?
Wobei...
...wahrscheinlich kostengünstiger...
...USB auf SATA ist.
Und nehm eine SSD, die nicht zu viel Strom verbraucht.
Du musst aufs Klo.
Excellent.
EA wird immer schlimmer.
Ist das so?
Das müssen wir uns nachher mal angucken.
Okay, Leute.
Wir lassen uns LevelCapture baiten.
Oh, ne.
Wenn ich den Titel schon lese.
Battlefield 2020 New Map Teaser Datamind.
Jawoll!
Leute!
Sechs Monate, sieben Monate nach Release.
Es kommt eine neue Map!
Endlich!
Wir haben alle drauf gewartet.
Alle...
Moment.
...übrig gebliebenen...
...3676 Leute.
Und 3414 Leute haben darauf gewartet.
Ich nicht.
Ich bin da durch.
Wenn da...
Wenn da jetzt für dieses Game nicht noch irgendwas riesiges kommt, wovon ich nicht ausgehe, bin ich damit durch.
Okay, zeigt mal her.
A dataminer uncovered new Battlefield 2042 content.
Modern Warfare 2 was revealed...
Ich finde übrigens Dataminer so gut.
Das hört sich immer so an, als...
...als, ähm...
...lassen die da, keine Ahnung, irgendwelche Kenntnisse.
Keine Ahnung, irgendwelche Grafikkarten.
Äh...
...zwei Wochen irgendwelche Battlefield-Teile...
...Files analysieren und haben das dann datamined oder so.
Das ist ja Blödsinn.
Du guckst dir...
Also die...
...die einfachste Form vom dataminen ist, keine Ahnung, du machst irgendwelche Files mit einem Hex-Editor auf...
...oder lässt dir Strings extrahieren aus Dateien.
Das geht ja relativ einfach.
Ähm...
...und...
...guckst, was drinsteht.
Natürlich gibt's da zwar bestimmt auch die ein oder anderen komplizierteren Techniken, aber...
...das hört sich so...
...so super, wie soll ich sagen, so...
...so super sophisticated abgedreht, hochwissenschaftlich an.
Die meisten Leute machen tatsächlich sowas.
Binwalk oder Strings oder...
...im Zweifelsfall einfach auch nur einen Hex-Editor auf- und drüber scrollen.
So, zeig mal her.
Ja, es ist übrigens...
Eins haben wir gelernt, Leute. Habt ihr den Modern Warfare 2 Teaser gesehen?
Es ist nicht...
...teaser.
Genau.
Kann man das nicht ins Fullscreen machen auf dem PC oder was?
Was ist denn das?
Alter!
Dieser Zoomer-Scheiß, Mann!
Was ist das denn?
Wer hat sich das überlegt?
Also, ich kann den Kram auf dem Smartphone ohne Probleme in Fullscreen machen.
Ich mein halt, halt wenn ich's...
Auf dem Desktop hat das so Balken, das ist mir klar.
Aber mit Balken ist es trotzdem größer als hier.
Shorts durch Watch.
Wirklich?
PyFat, alter, der Chat wieder.
Excellent.
So.
Passt mal auf, es ist nicht Modern Warfare 2.
Es ist Modern 2 Warfare.
Nicht Modern Warfare 2. Wir haben uns getäuscht.
Okay, ich geb zu.
Cringe, cringe joke.
Ja, okay.
Ist gut.
Weiter.
Gameplay-Reveal might happen soon and much more on this week in gaming.
Battlefield Data Miner Temporial has uncovered new content in Battlefield 2042's most recent update.
An unused player card...
Wisst ihr, was ich geil finde bei LevelCap?
Der macht zwar jede Woche irgendwie noch in irgendeiner Art und Weise Battlefield in seine News, aber...
Bock, das Game zu spielen, hat er auch nicht mehr, weil das ist immer nur Trailer-Footage.
Und das Geile ist, im Trailer sieht das ja auch noch ganz brauchbar aus.
Der Trailer hat uns alle so verarscht.
Ähm...
Das ist wirklich grenzwertig.
Es ist ja normal, dass Trailer quasi die Sachen, die da sind, besonders geschönt darstellen.
Aber die haben in dem Trailer Dinger gezeigt, die gar nicht vorhanden sind in dem Spiel.
Und...
Sag mal, das, was vorhanden ist, maximal missverständlich dargestellt, ja?
... background depicts 2042-era tanks missed a massive blizzard.
Das ist ein Panzer mit nem Schneeschieber!
Was soll denn das geben, wenn's fertig ist?
AI-Soldiers!
Ja gut, AI-Soldiers brauchst du ja auch, weil keiner mehr das Spiel spielt.
Super, ein Tank mit nem Schneeschieber!
Perfekt!
Dass da noch keiner drauf gekommen ist, Leute!
Da brauchen die bis 2042, bis die sowas erfinden.
Aber eigentlich ist doch ein Schneeschieber an nem Panzer total bescheuert, oder?
Jetzt mal ernsthaft!
Du willst ja mit nem Panzer nicht zwangsläufig die Straße freimachen.
Du willst mit dem Panzer vorwärtskommen.
Dementsprechend brauchst du ja auch keinen Schneeschieber am Panzer.
Also das ist ja...
Also das ergibt doch wenig Sinn.
Egal!
... also found numerous snow-themed weapon skins hidden in the update 4.0 files.
The initial loading screen for the game currently features snowy mountain peaks in the background.
According to Temprial, the loading screen...
Moment, ist mein Lautstärke stimmig. Doch, doch, doch.
Lautstärke ist okay, oder?
... relates somehow to the unannounced exposure map.
Speculation suggests that this map is coming with the Season 1 update.
Okay, im Juni! Im Juni!
... the correlation Temprial has drawn between his...
... findings and the new...
By the way, könnt ihr euch grad erinnern, wie cool das im Trailer aussah und wie lame das Ingame aussieht?
... loading screen is interesting, but it's tough to say for sure if DICE are officially teasing the new map or not.
Temprial also uncovered new assets. These include falling rocks, busted pipes...
Oh!
... metal detectors, flickering lights...
Falling rocks?
... Season 1...
Das gab's ja noch nie.
Falling rocks, also jetzt.
... one of the Battle Passes set to launch in the early summer...
Ne! Next gen!
Wahnsinnig nice next gen!
... stay tuned in the future for the official announcements coming about Season 1 for Battlefield 2042.
Activision and developers at Infinity Ward published the logo and teaser animation for this year's Call of Duty game.
And while the teaser is very...
By the way, mit Modern Warfare 2, oder mit Modern 2 Warfare, ist die Storyline eh komplett im Arsch.
Bisher konnte man auch sagen, hey, Modern Warfare 1 von 2019 war ja quasi so die...
... Vorgeschichte zu Modern Warfare.
Das sieht man auch im Outro, wo er irgendwas von SOAP und Task Force 141 und sowas erzählt.
Natürlich hat damals schon nicht alles gepasst und sie haben dann gesagt, ja, das ist nur inspiriert und wäre ja ein anderes Universum und bla bla bla bla bla.
Aber spätestens jetzt, damit ist es eh komplett vorbei.
Es ergibt eigentlich nichts mehr zusammengenommen Sinn.
Very short.
It does confirm...
Nicht, dass es wahnsinnig schlimm wäre für das Game, aber...
It's a direct sequel to 2019's Modern Warfare, called Modern Warfare 2.
Ich find's immer noch bescheuert, dass das ein Ding ist überhaupt, ja.
Es war klar, dass es kommt, weil es hat sich saumäßig gut verkauft 2019.
Sicherlich auch aus dem Nostalgiefaktor, weil viele Leute gesagt haben, oh ja, Modern Warfare war damals geil, jetzt kommt es neu.
Das wird sich wieder gut verkaufen, hundertprozentig.
Ich find's aber absolutes Armutszeugnis, hab ich auch schon mal im Video gesagt, dass es überhaupt quasi...
...ein Reboot gibt von Modern Warfare.
Von einem Game.
Ja, Modern Warfare ist ein Game.
Also das ist nicht so alt, es ist nicht so, dass es technisch jetzt irgendwie wahnsinnig schlecht wäre oder so.
Dass da jetzt quasi ein Game rebooted wird, was...
...keine Ahnung, zehn Jahre alt ist oder so.
Und...
...maßgeblich die Serie zu dem gemacht hat, was es heute ist.
Also warum...
Ups.
Warum rebooten?
Ich versteh dieses ganze Reboot an allen Ecken nicht.
Also ich...
...aus wirtschaftlicher Sicht schon.
Aber...
...aus kreativer Sicht ist es doch absolut abfuck.
Da hat doch auch keiner Bock dran zu arbeiten.
Deswegen fühlen sich die ganzen Games auch so...
...so seelenlos vom Fließband an.
Weil die kreativen Leute halt...
...Dienst nach Vorschrift machen.
Also da kommt ein Game, das in den Punkt geht, und die angehört dort zu Singapore.
Activision hat noch nicht viel über das Game gesagt, sie sagten aber, dass Modern Warfare 2 und die neue Warzone-Erfahrung dazu laufen, aber dass sie vontv herausgebaut sind und aus dem Grunde her groundbreaking Innovationen dazu machen.
Aber das war nur ihre offizielle Kommentierung, auf die das Game nämlich geht.
Moment, Moment!
Da kann nichts China-Kritisches drin sein in dem Game.
Dann kommt nämlich Tencent an und sagt, ne ne Leute, Activision Blizzard, das mag die Masche doch nicht.
Hahaha
Wo käme der denn da hin?
...wäre da was China-Kritisches drin, ja.
Star Wars Jedi Fallen of theículos.
Next Gen Only? Wollt ihr...
Leute, die Next Gen Konsolen sind schon wieder zwei Jahre alt.
Kann man da wirklich von Next Gen sprechen?
Wann kam die PS5 raus?
2002? Okay, eineinhalb Jahre.
Also kann man doch von Next Gen sprechen, wenn die Hardware schon eineinhalb Jahre raus ist?
Ich denke nicht. Wie seht ihr das, Chat?
Also für mich ist Next Gen spätestens zu Release ist es eigentlich nicht mehr Next Gen.
Aber eineinhalb Jahre nach Release ist es definitiv nichts mehr Next Gen.
Es ist aktuelle Current Gen.
Durch die schlechte Verfügbarkeit.
Ich denke die meisten Leute, die eine PS5 haben wollen, haben mittlerweile eine PS5.
Aber streng genommen ist das nach Release nicht Next Gen.
Ich meine, gerade zu Xbox 360 hat man sehr lange Next Gen gesagt.
Xbox 360 kam wann raus? 2006 oder so?
Und ähm...
2005?
Man hat quasi noch drei, vier Jahre Next Gen gesagt zu Xbox 360.
Yeay!
Ouh!
Ich hab's mir kurz überlegt...
Ihr wisst, ich habe glaube ich kaum ein Game die letzten Jahre so hart und lang am Stück gecrintet wie Overwatch
...
immerhin Top 500 Season 1, ja, im Boomer-Alter damals schon,
aber ganz ehrlich, es schockt mich nicht,
ich verstehe auch nicht so genau, was an Overwatch 2 jetzt das 2 im Namen rechtfertigt,
ich habe es auf Twitter schon gesagt, in anderen Games ist das ein Season-Update,
was sie gemacht haben ist, von 6 auf 5 Mann verringert,
wie gut sich das am Ende spielt, weiß ich nicht,
ich könnte mir vorstellen, das wird schon passen,
es gibt einen neuen Held, einen neuen Spielmodus und irgendwie eine neue Map oder sowas,
das ist in anderen Games ein Season-Update, wenn überhaupt,
und das, was ich bisher vom PvE und dem Story-Modus gesehen habe,
das war ja noch nicht viel, aber das, was man gesehen hat,
sieht aus wie irgendein 2-Mann-Modder-Projekt,
also nicht irgendwie super, wie soll ich sagen,
nicht jetzt irgendwie, dass man sagt, boah, das ist ja quasi so atmosphärisch
und eigene Welt und sonst wie, das sah aus wie ein 2-Mann-Modder-Projekt,
was man bisher gesehen hat vom Singleplayer,
und Overwatch krankt an so vielen Stellen,
von Sachen wie Balancing fangen wir mal gar nicht an,
Overwatch-Balancing, ich habe es schon oft gesagt, ist typisches Blizzard-Balancing,
Paint, was ist denn das?
Overwatch-Balancing ist typisches Blizzard-Balancing,
Blizzard-Balancing sieht so aus, also keine Ahnung,
das Spiel, nehmen wir es mal für einen Held, das Spiel kommt raus,
Held ist OP, Held ist OP, hier, hier ist OP,
so, Held ist OP, Held ist OP, erster Patch kommt,
Held ist kacke, Held ist kacke, Held ist kacke, Held ist kacke, Held ist kacke, Held ist kacke, Held ist kacke,
irgendwann kommt Rework, Held ist OP, Held ist OP, Held ist OP,
Nerf, Held ist wieder mega kacke, mega, das ist Blizzard-Balancing,
das ist Blizzard-Balancing, das machen die in allen Games,
kriegen es nicht geschissen und keine ahnung also davon will ich gar nicht
mehr anfangen das ist ein generelles problem was die was den overwatch anfang
an haben was was ich viel blöder finde ist dass blizzard beispielsweise immer
gesagt hat overwatch soll hier das neue der neue e spot hit werden null es ist
überhaupt nicht overwatch league ist so unbedeutend wie nie zuvor und es gibt
keine außer overwatch league jetzt ich weiß dass es contenders gibt aber mal
ehrlich content das wird nirgendwo richtig geworben content das guckt kein
content das juckt keinen jedes regional also wenn die wenn die skandinavischen
länder was weiß ich king of scandinavia cs turnier machen keine ahnung ob so
was gibt aber gehen wir mal von aus das hat 20 mal mehr viewer als overwatch
content
und das ist irgendein regional event content das ist theoretisch tier 2 also
tier was bescheuert ist weil das gibt's den overwatch nicht so also es gibt es
gibt den overwatch kein e sport außerhalb overwatch league und es gibt
dementsprechend kein tier 2 kein tier 3 kein nachwuchs nichts
es ist dead as fuck im e sport overwatch obwohl blizzard das groß als der
nächsten e sport shit angekündigt hat die könnten die hätten so unbedeutend
unglaublich viel für dieses game machen können
automatisch generierte in game weakly zum beispiel turniere hätte man
ohne probleme machen können natürlich für automatisch generiert
seinéral also man hätte die ganze e sport gesicht wenn man die dann machen
möchte wenn man dann sagt dieses spiel soll in
richtung e sport z k k k könnte das ist keine tossed sl reporter
hätte man so viel mehr machen können es ist nicht so dass es an ideen da mangelt
aus irgendwelchen gründen möchte blizzard nicht so dazu kommt dass es
kaum neuen content gibt also wie gesagt ball satisfy der historia-test noch mal
abgekuckt kaum neuen content gibt der hat sich jetzt leider an dem Snorke hormones
ein prophet wird zum Beispiel sogar die maschinen und wirtflussmann ist der Hintergrund von William
einfach ein Getränkelehrer und klar kein solve negative ganze coughing mal malaria
Overwatch. Wisst ihr, wann der letzte Overwatch
Short-Film rausgekommen ist?
2018.
Das war, glaube ich, mit McCree und
Echo. Sorry, sorry. McCree.
Oh nein.
Das wäre ich gleich. Nicht McCree.
Cassidy.
Sorry. Das war ja, das darf man
ja gar nicht mehr sagen.
Sonst sind die Leute triggert.
Das war der letzte Kurzfilm.
2018. Da hieß er aber noch so.
2018.
Die haben weder
Lore und Geschichte
und Story gebracht für die
Gelegenheits-Casual-Spieler. Die stehen da zum
größten Teil drauf. Ich muss sagen, ich fand
die Overwatch-Lore und die Kurzfilme
richtig gut. Ich halte
den Bestchen-Kurzfilm
tatsächlich für eines
der besten Dinger, die
in dieser Richtung rausgekommen sind.
Der Bestchen-Kurzfilm ist richtig gut, unabhängig
davon, ob du Overwatch spielst oder nicht.
Die anderen
gingen auch so, aber der Bestchen-Kurzfilm, den fand ich
richtig gut.
Sehr gut, ja.
So, und dann hat
Overwatch immer noch kaum, jetzt immer noch
kaum Content. Die haben es irgendwie geschafft, in
drei Jahren zwei Maps zu veröffentlichen
und zwei Helden oder sowas.
Vielleicht waren es auch drei, ja.
Die Maps, die in dem Spiel drin sind,
sind zu 50% immer noch Müll.
Ja, ich
sag nur 2CP Temple of Anubis
oder sowas. Das ist immer noch am Start.
Es ist seriously
eine Map mit Capture Points
drin oder Volskaya Industries.
Es ist wirklich Maps mit Capture Points
drin, wo das Spawn
immer noch zwei Meter
hinterm Capture Point ist.
An sich ist
Capture Point, ich weiß, das haben
die rausgeschmissen, ja, aber, hallo,
das Spiel ist 2016
oder so rausgekommen. Warum ist das
immer noch ein Ding in der heutigen Zeit? Das haben sie zum Glück
jetzt rausgespielt, 2CP. Gut,
das liegt bestimmt aber auch daran mit der Reduktion
von 6 auf 5. 2CP, der
beschwachsinnigste Modus überhaupt.
Eigentlich ist 2CP
gar nicht schlecht, aber in Kombination mit den Maps
ist es wirklich hängen geblieben.
Ne, es ist keine Gründe,
Overwatch 2 zu kaufen, weil der Multiplayer-Part
wird zwischen Overwatch 1 und Overwatch 2
geshared. Du kannst Overwatch 1
behalten, das kommt ja noch dazu.
Ich glaub nur das Grafik-Update und
ähm,
der Singleplayer ist Overwatch 2
exclusive. Warum gibt es eigentlich
keine guten Maps mehr? Tja,
weil Blizzard anscheinend keine Shooter-Maps
bauen kann. Ich weiß es nicht. Also generell
muss ich sagen, die Overwatch-Maps
sind von
Details her,
äh, Design her und so
von der
vom Artwork und allem
sind die wirklich ganz gut.
Aber vom Aufbau her
und der
Platzierung von Objectives und
Capture-Points, ich weiß
nicht, ich find das nicht gut. Die sind zum
größten Teil auch
zu linear.
Du hast ja in Overwatch im Prinzip,
gerade bei
Assault und sowas
hast du in Overwatch im Prinzip
einen Weg, den du gehen kannst,
mit drei Chokepoints zwischendurch,
wo du deinen Kart durchpushen musst.
Also, ich weiß nicht, also
Maps waren noch nie,
aber die Hälfte der Maps von Overwatch
kannst du eigentlich knicken und gäbe es
in Overwatch ein Map-Voting-System,
könnte man
davon ausgehen, dass 50% der Maps
weggevotet werden. Tja,
aber mir ist es ein absolutes,
riesiges Rätsel, wie man es schaffen kann,
das Riesenpotential, was in Overwatch
drinnen steckte,
so über die Jahre
nicht zu nutzen, wie das Blizzard gemacht hat.
Keine Ahnung, verstehe ich nicht.
Obwohl da so viele
mega highly paid
Professionals sitzen, die eigentlich wissen, was sie machen.
Tja, von technischer
Seite aus
und auch, wie gesagt,
Grafik-Stil, ist
Overwatch wirklich ein saumäßig gutes Spiel.
Also, es gibt wenig, aber es ist auch ein sehr gutes Spiel.
gibt wenig und ich habe also ich spiele multiplayer spiele seit 56 km oder im
zeiten half life 1 online also ich habe einige multiplayer spiele gesehen über
die letzten jahre und ich muss sagen kein spiel kein multi also kein pvp
multiplayer shooter hat sich so gut vom von der von der netzwerkseite angefühlt
wie overwatch overwatch hat seine probleme mit
manchmal dass hits nicht registriert werden und so was okay da kannst aber im
prinzip nichts dagegen machen wenn wirklich mal dummerweise irgendwas
verloren geht also dass das problem hat jedes game aber in overwatch ist
insgesamt die netzwerk performance das beste was ich kenne
kein game sagt mir in den game was daran kommt overwatch fühlt sich einfach gut
an vom vom rein vom netzwerk multiplayer aspekt da leckt nichts dazu geht nix da
mit rechts in der regel auch da wirst du nicht um die ecke gekillt
da wirst du nicht irgendwie gehittet von dingern die noch nicht sehen kannst das
ist einfach gut gemacht da kannst du da kannst du nicht sagen
und weil er weiß ich nicht wenn das habe ich nicht gespielt
das ist einfach gut und das wird ich doppelt kacke dass sie
das eigentliche potenzial in diesem spiel irgendwie so links liegen lassen
sei froh dass die kein walk auf vier ausgebracht haben guck dir mal an was
aus walk third die ford geworden ist stell dir mal vor die gleiche leute würden heute war griff er für uns mit dir hier im video
deforged geworden ist. Stell dir mal vor,
die gleichen Leute würden heute Warcraft 4 rausbringen.
Die wissen
nicht mal, wie das funktioniert.
Das ist ein bisschen wie bei DICE und Battlefield.
Die haben ja mal gesagt, sie wissen gar nicht
mehr, wie man ein Bad Company 2 macht.
Mittlerweile wissen wir, es geht nicht mehr, wie man ein
Bad Company macht.
Mittlerweile wissen wir,
dass sie nicht mehr wissen, wie man
ein Bad Company macht. Sie wissen auch nicht mehr, wie man ein Battlefield macht.
Das war nicht gelogen, das stimmt.
Und so ähnlich stelle ich mir mal Blizzard
auch vor. Die haben keine Ahnung mehr, wie man
ein gutes Warcraft 4 machen würde.
Bei StarCraft
wursteln sie sich ja auch ab seit
zig Jahren.
Sodass sehr viele Pros mittlerweile
sogar wieder lieber StarCraft 1 spielen.
According to the game's director, the lower
player count should speed up the gameplay.
New maps have been created and the heroes...
Twitter!
Twitter ist wieder zu geil gewesen.
Twitter war wieder
extrem, extrem
woke, was den neuen Overwatch-Held angeht,
habe ich gelesen.
Twitter übertreibt es ja da teilweise, ja.
Und wir wissen alle, Overwatch hat schon einen
äußerst diversen Cast
an Characters. Da ist eigentlich alles dabei, ja.
Von Asiaten
bis Schwarze, bis, äh,
äh,
Japaner,
äh, Russen,
äh, Deutsche, ist alles
dabei in Overwatch, ja. Also,
gut wie alle Geschlechter, so gut wie alle Hautfarben
ist es alles dabei, ja.
Äh, Schwule, Lesben, alles dabei
bei Overwatch. Aber
jetzt gibt es einen, einen, einen
weiblichen schwarzen Held und da haben sich die Leute
auf Twitter tatsächlich aufgeregt, so nach dem
Motto, jetzt wurde es aber auch
mal Zeit mit Blizzard. Wie
konnte es sein, dass schwarze Frauen
so lange unterrepräsentiert waren in Overwatch?
Und da denke ich mir auch immer, Leute,
meine Güte, lasst doch mal die Kirche
im Dorf, Alter.
Es ist in Overwatch, es, mir fällt
kein Game ein, was
so sehr durch die Bank weg,
alles, was es auf der Welt in irgendeiner, gibt
in irgendeiner Weise repräsentiert wie Overwatch.
Und jetzt
ist das auch nicht,
jetzt reicht es auch nicht, dass das jetzt,
nein, das hätte schon immer sein, also
bei den Leuten weiß ich nicht, was bei denen im Kopf abgeht.
Das ist genauso, die Leute,
die sich damals aufgeregt haben,
über, dass Tracer lesbisch ist,
sie haben sich nicht darüber aufgeregt, dass
Tracer lesbisch ist, sondern sie haben gesagt,
das darf nicht sein, weil Tracer ist
ein Charakter, der explizit für das
männliche Auge designt wurde.
Und deswegen darf die in der Story nicht lesbisch sein.
Keine Ahnung, du kannst
es Twitter nicht recht machen,
das ist unmöglich.
Du hast immer genug Leute,
aber ich meine, die verdienen ja auch viele auf Twitter anscheinend
ihr Geld mit empört sein und sich
darüber aufregen.
Wirklich Probleme machen, wo keine sind.
Letztendlich kann man
immer sagen, künstlerische Freiheit.
Und ich bin auch
der Meinung, die sollen designen, was für das Game
gut ist. Die sollen designen,
was für das Game gut ist.
Und fertig, aus, gut ist.
Ja, umgedreht
der Fall,
war es, wo sie sich,
wo sie sich drüber aufgeregt wurde,
von der anderen Seite jetzt auf Twitter,
dass es jetzt in der Herr-der-Ringe-Serie
eine schwarze Zwergenprinzipie
gibt oder sowas in der Richtung.
Da haben sich die Leute auch drüber aufgeregt.
Und da wurde dann drauf geantwortet, ja,
künstlerische Freiheit. Ja, was denn jetzt mehr?
Kann ich einmal so sagen und einmal so sagen?
Ich bin der Meinung,
die Leute, die die kreative Freiheit
über ein Produkt haben, sollen erstmal das machen,
nämlich dafür sorgen, dass da ein gutes
Produkt bei rauskommt.
Das ist das Wichtigste, auch für mich als Käufer.
Das, was ich kaufe,
das Negativbeispiel ist Battlefield 2042.
Battlefield 2042 ist anscheinend,
ein tolles Spiel.
Das macht es nicht besser dadurch,
dass jetzt vielleicht dort
alle möglichen Leute repräsentiert sind.
Das Erste, was gut sein muss,
ist das Spiel.
Und das ist es bei Battlefield 2042 nicht.
Also es ist dadurch
weder besser noch schlechter.
Oh Mann, aber
Twitter, Alter,
Twitter ist bei diesem Thema echt
komplett los.
Ja, da bin ich mal gespannt.
Da bin ich mal gespannt.
Der PvE-Modus ist das,
was es reißen muss für das Game.
Das ist das Einzige,
was
irgendwie
eine Kaufberechtigung hat.
Da habe ich meine Zweifel,
dass das, also ich meine,
die Hitbox,
die von Overwatch sind ja schon
nicht verkehrt, aber
dass man hier durchschießen kann
zwischen Echos Flügel und dem
Na gut, die hat vorher schon geschossen.
Wobei, ne, die hat gehittet, oder?
Microsoft hat es eröffnet,
dass es das Xbox- und Bethesda-Game
veröffentlicht hat.
Das Event wird am Sonntag,
am 12. Juni,
um 10 Uhr am Pazifik-Zeit.
Laut ihrer offiziellen Presse-Verleihung
wird das Spiel
großartige Titel
von Xbox Game Studios
Bethesda
und ihren verschiedenen Partnern.
Wegen des Spacetheemed-Branding-Events
spekulieren die Fans,
dass das höchst erwartete
Sci-Fi-RPG Starfield
von Bethesda
eine Auszeichnung machen wird.
Das bezieht sich auf
den normalen Eröffnungs-Schedule des Studios.
Seine Spiele werden typisch
im Sommer gefeiert,
bevor sie im Winter veröffentlicht werden.
Apex Legends,
Season 13,
genannt Saviors,
beginnt im ersten Mai.
Hä, was hat denn der Master Chief jetzt mit, ähm...
Ach, Moment, die haben die ja gekauft!
Ich hab schon,
wieder verdrängt!
Die haben die ja gekauft!
Keck, wait, alter!
Das vergesse ich immer wieder!
Weak players were treated to the
launch trailer
Und bald, und bald auch Activision!
It introduced a brand new legend
named Newcastle.
His full ability set is unknown,
though the trailer does show him deploying an energy shield
that can rotate on the spot.
He also appears to deploy a second barrier while
Gibt es, gibt es Mobs in Apex Legends?
Wusste ich gar nicht.
Gibt, gibt es,
gibt es, gibt es Monster in Apex Legends?
Ja.
Und, und...
Was bringt das, wenn man die killt?
...while reviving a fallen teammate.
Significant changes to the rank system are rumored for this new season.
It's believed that players will be able to derank to lower tiers.
This new system is supposedly going to emphasize skill and teamwork.
Map changes appear to be coming to Stormpoint, the game's latest edition.
Players expect this new season to drop on May 10th,
but no official confirmation has been shared yet.
Sony announced they are PlayStation Now and PlayStation Plus
Ich würde auch immer,
Ich würde auch immer in so einem Kriegsgebiet in einem Korsett rumlaufen.
Das ist, glaube ich, das allerbeste, was man da anziehen kann.
Sony announced they are PlayStation Now and PlayStation Plus Services
are merging in June.
This prompted users to buy both services, so
Die wollen, die wollen halt einfach ein bisschen was vom Xbox Game Pass abhaben,
beziehungsweise haben festgestellt, die haben nichts Vergleichbares
und sie werden wahrscheinlich auch nichts Vergleichbares haben.
but they would be automatically upgraded to the highest level.
tier of PlayStation Plus once it goes live.
This is a roundabout way of getting the highest tier for a much lower cost.
However, Sony caught on to this tactic quickly
and is now blocking the method.
Users report that their cards and consoles
are blocked from stacking the services.
You'll need to fork over the full $120 for an annual membership.
Zombie-Survival-Game Dying Light 2 got a critical update.
The game has received a new Game Plus option.
and new mutated enemies.
New Game Plus allows players to replay the campaign with altered game mechanics.
The changes include tweaked enemy behavior,
additional objectives on the map,
new parkour challenges and more.
The update also adds the mutated infected mission.
It features new goon variants on top of the new content.
Spielt das jemand noch aktiv?
Ich hab gelesen, ich hab letztens, ich glaube in irgendeinem Reddit Thread gelesen,
dass das Endgame, wenn man das so nennen kann,
äußerst, also mega repetitive sein muss.
... while also making some UI improvements.
The Survival-Zombie-Looter DayZ
has beaten its all-time peak player count record on Steam this week.
Was?
Warum hat DayZ auf einmal wieder Spieler?
Ich dachte, das ist seit vier Jahren out.
... its website, the new record stands at...
The fuck?
Wie jetzt?
Waren irgendwelche Streamer-Turniere oder was?
...
Buah baby
Blood Dragon und Rage...
Assassin's Creed 2 hatte einen Online-Modus?
Ach stimmt, die hatten mit den Add-Ons, hatten die dieses...
Ja gut, das wurde eh keiner gespielt.
...Famon Legends.
This update also affects achievements and item unlocks.
For example, in Assassin's Creed Brotherhood,
players must complete an online challenge
to unlock certain cosmetics.
Without the servers, this will become impossible.
And while this news is disappointing
for anyone who likes old school titles,
well, it doesn't affect Ubisoft's newest
or current releases.
Ey, des wär ja noch schöner.
Tja, so ist es halt.
Denn heute sind Games halt zum größten Teil ein Service.
Und das wird in Zukunft noch deutlich mehr Games so gehen.
Und gerade Games mit Always-On-Funktion,
die werden dann einfach komplett nicht mehr funktionieren.
Alien Isolation,
the survival horror game from Creative Assembly,
is getting a behind-the-scenes novel.
Andy Kelly, an experienced writer who worked with Vice,
PC Gamer and The Guardian,
is writing a companion novel called Perfect Organism.
According to...
Ja, das sind die Server für...
Das finde ich auch nicht schlimm.
Aber man muss mal gucken, was da alles dabei ist.
Es ist aber halt blöd, dass du Xbox-Achievements
und sowas da dran gebunden hast, ja?
Es gibt ja Leute, die wollen...
Die sind so richtig Completionist-mäßig unterwegs.
Die holen sich Games nur, um sie halt auf 1200 Gamerscore
oder was auch Maximum in den Games ist, zu spielen.
Und das geht jetzt halt nicht mehr.
Das ist schon doof.
Dann könnten sie es wenigstens so machen,
dass ich automatisch die Multiplayer-Achievements jetzt...
Entlocken lassen.
Dann werden zwar alle sagen,
die für die Multiplayer-Achievements gecridert haben,
unfairer Scheiß,
aber besser als Achievements,
die nie wieder jemals erreichbar sind.
Nein!
Ich hoffe für gar nichts.
Hallo, ein Specialist ohne Map.
Und ein paar neue Icons.
Wahnsinn.
No map or do you want something different from Season 1?
Let us know in the comments below.
Ich habe keine Zeit, in letzter Zeit irgendwie großartig
was anderes zu machen als Arbeiten, Streamsoren,
ab und zu mal ein YouTube-Video zu machen,
bei mir daheim am Haus rumzubauen, aufzuräumen,
Technik hier zu machen und alle möglichen anderen Kram.
Ich komme nicht dazu, wirklich mich da in neue Spiele großartig
einzuarbeiten.
Da denke ich mir manchmal, manchmal wäre es sehr nice,
wenn ich 15 wäre oder 16 oder so wieder.
Da habe ich dann...
Da konnte ich noch 16 Stunden am Tag sitzen und spielen,
wenn ich wollte.
Heute tut mir der Arsch weh.
Nach vier Stunden oder so.
Katschi Bass, Alter.
Was ist aus dem Zertifikat geworden?
Das hat funktioniert, aber es wurde ausgetauscht
unter 24 Stunden vor dem Ablauf.
...when a Spanish PlayStation fan account found a job listing
for Naughty Dog on LinkedIn.
It calls for a QA-Tester for an unannounced remake project.
Rumors of a Last of Us remake have been circulating for quite a while
and whether anything comes of it remains to be seen.
And that wraps it up for this week in gaming.
As always, guys, thank you so much for watching
and I'll catch you next time.
This is LevelCap signing off.
Der Friseur, ja.
Mit dem habe ich vereinzelt in letzter Zeit noch Kontakt, ja.
Wir haben halt leider keine Spiele aktuell,
die man zusammen spielen kann.
Aber ansonsten, klar, habe ich mit dem Friseur noch Kontakt.
Ich meine, ich kannte den Friseur ja auch schon lange vor YouTube.
Also, warum sollte ich keinen Kontakt mehr haben mit dem?
Es ist äußerst selten.
Letztes Jahr gar nicht mehr.
Aber es liegt auch zum größten Teil an mir.
Ich meine, ich könnte mich ja auch mal wieder melden.
Aber ich bin halt
Pepega-Social-Kerl.
Bebega.
Gibt es das eigentlich?
Bebega?
War klar!
Natürlich gibt es Bebega.
Okay, das ist aber ziemlich bescheuert.
Das ist aber ziemlich bescheuert.
Das sind bescheuerte Emotes.
Zum Krieger habe ich eigentlich so gut wie keinen Kontakt mehr.
Ich glaube, das letzte Mal war irgendwie...
Das letzte Mal, wo ich mit dem Krieger gesprochen habe,
ist bestimmt schon vier Jahre her.
Ab und zu mal auf Twitter ein bisschen.
Aber wir haben auch wenig Überschneidungen.
Ich habe bei ihm letztens den Stream reingeguckt.
Da hat er irgendein komisches Jäger-Game gespielt,
wo er mit der Hirschflöte durch den Wald gelaufen ist
und dann Hirsche abgesnipert hat und sowas.
Ich habe gesagt, was zum Teufel ist das?
Was spielt der denn da?
So war...
Ja, ja, doch, genau das.
Das war es.
Ja, jetzt erinnere ich mich wieder an den Titel.
Irgend so ein Jäger-Game hat er gespielt.
Komm, hat er Krieger eben.
Das war Zeit, ne?
Du müsstest mal ein German Taters Rewatch machen.
Das ist so outdated, die Videos.
Weiß nicht, was man da rewatchen soll.
Das Spiel ist schön zum Entspannen.
Okay.
Weiß ich.
Ich fand es jetzt nicht so spannend.
Oder entspannend oder überhaupt so, dass ich das...
Hat jemand mal das da ausprobiert?
Das finde ich, sieht richtig nice aus.
Das ist ein deutsches Game.
Das finde ich, sieht richtig nice aus für entspannendes Game.
Guck mal, ist auch overwhelming positive.
Ist ganz nice.
Ja, habe ich auch.
Ich habe letztens ein GameStar Review gesehen.
Habe ja auch gesagt, das ist ein richtig nice Entspannungs-Game.
Ich weiß, deswegen habe ich mir das auch aufgefallen,
weil es gerade released wurde.
So ein Entspannungs-Game könnte ich mir schon noch geben.
Das könnte ich auch super als Hintergrund-Gameplay nehmen.
Einfach weil, wenn ich mal irgendwas habe,
wo man eigentlich einfach nur ein bisschen nebenbei zuhören muss,
ist das wunderbar.
So, was haben wir da alles?
Was gibt es eigentlich neu?
Ich will nicht Rohrbauer.
Ich will wissen, haben die was anderes?
Vertriebstrainerin, Rezeptionistin, Rohrleitungsbauer, IT-Administrator.
Das haben wir schon geguckt, oder?
Ah ja, das waren die mit den Unify-Access Points.
Leute, ich bin mit meinem Unify-Zeug nicht mehr zufrieden.
Ich bin mir noch unschlüssig, ob ich mal was anderes ausprobieren sollte.
Ich bin, also, es gibt zwei Sachen, warum ich mit meinem Unify-Zeug noch mal glücklich bin.
Das erste ist, weil ich aus irgendwelchen nicht verständlichen Gründen
Verbindungsabbrüche habe mit meinem, oder nicht nur mit meinem iPhone,
mit den iPads und dem iPhone.
Verbindungsabbrüche insofern, dass du machst deine Webseite auf
und es dauert dann einfach zehn Sekunden, bis er sich richtig zum Access Point connected hat.
Verstehe ich nicht, warum.
Keine Ahnung, ist nicht immer so, ist selten so, aber es nervt.
Die Access Points sind auch, weiß nicht, merkwürdig, was Ausleuchtung angeht.
Ich meine, mein Haus ist nicht sonderlich groß hier.
Das ist jetzt nicht, dass es irgendwie eine 500 Quadratmeter Villa wäre, oder so.
Es ist halt Keller, Erdgeschoss, erster Stock, Dach.
So.
Und
ich habe,
im Erdgeschoss, äh, ich habe im Keller einen Access Point.
Im Erdgeschoss.
Ähm, im ersten Stock.
Wahrscheinlich bräuchte ich den im Erdgeschoss gar nicht.
Denke ich jetzt einfach mal.
Ich habe auch extra die WiFi-Sende, Sendestärke runtergestellt,
dass sich das nicht so sehr überlagert.
So.
Und dann habe ich noch einen vierten Access Point,
der ist am Fenster raus zur Terrasse,
dass ich auch quasi ein bisschen Garten-WLAN habe.
Ich finde es allein schon bescheuert, dass ich vier Access Points oder drei bis vier Access Points überhaupt brauche.
Ich meine, das ist ja Oldschool-Haus mit fetten Wänden und so.
Das ist nicht einfach, äh, Ami-Holzbauweise oder so.
Das ist schon massiv, ja, was der Opa hier gebaut hat.
Oder, eigentlich hat es der Ur-Ur-Uropa gebaut, der dann nach Südafrika abgehauen ist.
Ähm, und, das gefällt mir nicht.
Und was mir auch nicht gefällt ist, dass die ein Feature,
dass den ein Feature fehlt, was ich unbedingt haben will.
Nämlich, extra Passwörter für IoT-Clients.
Also, dass du beispielsweise eine WLAN, äh, Steckdose, WLAN, LED-Lampe,
dass du der ein eigenes WLAN-Passwort geben kannst.
Weil dann kannst du die Lampe auch wegschmeißen,
das löschen, und, ähm, dann liegt dein WLAN-Passwort nicht im Müll.
Das ist immer noch was, was mir überhaupt nicht vom Verfahren gefällt, wie IoT-Geräte
in der Regel betrieben werden.
Dass man ein WLAN-Passwort hat, wo alles rein, also ein WLAN hat, wo alles reinkommt, und
sobald du das Gerät wegschmeißt, liegt dein WLAN-Passwort im Müll.
Das finde ich kacke.
So, und Unify hat dieses Feature nicht.
So ziemlich alle, so ziemlich jeder andere etwas teurere, sogar MikroTik-Anbieter von
WLAN-Hardware hat das.
Ja.
Doch, die meisten haben das.
Die meisten, die, die meisten, also wenn man jetzt mal von den, von den billigen Dingern
absieht, ja, also von irgendwelchen unmanaged TP-Link-Dingern, oder, wobei, unmanaged gibt's
ja bei Access Points nicht, von irgendwelchen TP-Link-Dingern oder Netgear-Dingern, also
wenn man mal rein von Consumer-Zeug absieht, MikroTik hat's, ähm, Cisco hat's, ähm,
Aruba hat's, äh, Ruckus hat's, wie auch immer man die ausspricht.
Also klar.
Die sind alle nicht billig und die sind zum größten Teil auch noch teurer als Unify,
außer MikroTik.
MikroTik hat's auch und der Kram ist ähnlich teuer, beziehungsweise günstiger als Unify-Sachen.
Aber ich, so, so, so gern ich MikroTik habe, was, ähm, Switcher und Router angeht, von
den MikroTik-Access Points bin ich nicht sonderlich überzeugt.
LAN-Com hat's auch, ja.
OpenWRT hat es mittlerweile auch.
Die haben einen Pull-Request.
Den kann man sich selbst merchen.
Oder?
Man weiß es nicht.
Man wartet, bis sie den gemerged haben.
Hier.
OpenWRT hat es mittlerweile theoretisch bald.
Wir sind gerade dabei, das zu merchen.
Dann haben sie es auch.
Und damit kannst du für jedes WLAN-Endgerät ein eigenes WLAN-Passwort vergeben.
Fortinet hat es bestimmt auch.
Die haben, es haben im Prinzip alle etwas teureren Anbieter, außer Unify.
Und es gibt auch tausende Threads.
Es gibt sogar jemanden, der das selbst gebaut hat.
Mit Custom-Config für Unify-Access-Points.
Es gibt tausende Threads.
Reddit, offizielles Unify-Forum.
Dass sie sagen, Leute, das ist ein echt wichtiges Feature.
Das brauchen wir.
Gerade für IoT-Sachen.
Aber die wollen nicht.
Die haben keinen Bock.
Und das ist ein Feature, was ich wirklich gerne hätte.
Nur mal so nebenbei angemerkt.
Ja, 2022.
Aber das letzte, der letzte Status ist von diesem Jahr, dass es gerade bei dem Core-Developer-Team
ist.
Ende letzten Jahres.
Und die das merchen wollen.
Im Zweifelsfall kann man das nicht.
Aber ich glaube, dass man das auch machen kann.
Ich glaube, dass man das auch machen kann.
Ich habe noch nie eine eigene Open-WRT-Version gebaut.
Richtig, richtige MVPs hier.
Dazu kann man bloß sagen.
Kann man die nicht mit Open-WRT flashen?
Teilweise.
Manche musst du auch mit Open-WRT flashen.
Manche musst du aufschrauben.
Aber nachdem Open-WRT offiziell das noch nicht hat, müsste ich mir Open-WRT selbst kompilieren.
Das habe ich noch nie gemacht.
Da bin ich nicht sonderlich scharf drauf.
Ich bin gerade am überlegen, ob ich mir nicht auf Ebay mal einen älteren, was weiß ich,
Ruckus oder sonst was Access Point kaufe für ein paar Euro und das mal ausprobiere da,
ob das was taugt.
Ja, ja, das bringt ja aber nichts, wenn Open-WRT, also ich kenne die Anleitung, wie man das,
wie man das flasht.
Manche musst du so, wie gesagt, manche musst du aufschreiben und sogar anlöten.
Aber es bringt mir ja nichts, wenn die Open-WRT-Version das Feature, was ich hatte, noch nicht drin
hat.
Weil selbst kompilieren möchte ich ehrlich gesagt Open-WRT nicht.
Eine was?
Eine MSI?
Was ist das?
Mobile Security?
Ne.
Multisession?
Ich habe keine Ahnung, was MSI ist.
Übrigens, MSI ist immer noch ein gutes Stichwort, Leute.
Lasst mich mal kurz mal was ausprobieren.
Ich muss, ich muss mal kurz was checken.
Äh, MSI, Germany?
Ähm.
Ich bin immer noch gebannt.
Mann, warum?
Warum, warum entbannen die mich nicht?
Wo ist Kammer?
Ich bin immer noch gebannt.
Und ich weiß einfach nicht, warum.
Und sie sagen es mir auch nicht.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Warum?
Ich weiß es nicht, was ich gemacht habe.
Ich habe keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß es wirklich nicht.
Du hättest zwei neue Videos.
Grafix.
Boah, das ist ganz schön lang.
Das gucken wir uns nicht jetzt an.
Ich mache das mal auf.
Vielleicht gucken wir uns das irgendwann demnächst an.
Meine Tabs sind so klein, dass ich die Tabs nicht mal anklicken kann.
Bestimmt.
Das wird es sein.
Das wäre es, ja.
Ich glaube nicht, dass er den MSI-Deutschland-Account, dass er sich dafür interessiert.
Ach so, ein Microsoft-Installer.
Ich habe es nicht in Zusammenhang gebracht mit WLAN jetzt.
Das hat aber mit WLAN nichts zu tun.
Aber ich habe ja gerade was über WLAN erzählt.
Ah, Mann.
So.
Was haben wir sonst noch zu gucken?
EA wird immer schlimmer.
Neun Minuten.
Okay, da bin ich mal gespannt.
Jetzt bin ich mal gespannt, warum EA immer schlimmer wird.
Ich meine, viel schlimmer kann es ja eigentlich nicht sein.
Aber ich kenne übrigens den Channel auch nicht.
Keine Ahnung.
Und 2013 wurde EA zu der meistgehassten Firma.
Ja.
Das ist so.
Aber danach haben sie gesagt, EA ist jetzt Consumer First und wir werden uns bessern.
Und sie haben sich nicht gebessert und sie haben es eigentlich noch schlimmer gemacht.
Aber aus irgendwelchen Gründen werden sie nicht mehr die meistgehasste Firma.
Das liegt aber nicht so sehr daran, dass EA besser geworden ist, sondern dass sie anderen
aufgeholt haben im Schlechtsein.
In den USA gewählt.
Ja.
Bei mir damals auf dem Schulhof hieß es, kauft keine EA-Spiele.
Denn EA ist der Teufel der Gaming-Branche.
Was soll ich sagen?
Ich persönlich habe mich an dieses Credo immer gehalten.
Aber meine lieben Jünger, auch ich habe gesündigt.
Nämlich 2018.
Damals kaufte ich bei meinem späteren Partner MMOGA Star Wars Battlefront.
Ist das ein Text to Speech?
Ist das Text to Speech?
Ja.
Moment.
Hört euch das mal an.
MMOGA.
Partner MMOGA.
Das hört sich an wie Text to Speech, Alter.
Star Wars Battlefront 2.
Ich hatte zu dem besagten Tag die Möglichkeit, mir für 3 Euro einen Döner zu kaufen.
Ja, damals waren einige Dönerläden noch ein bisschen günstiger als heute in Berlin.
Oder halt Battlefront 2.
Oh, cringe.
Das kann ich mir nicht angucken.
Sorry.
Nee.
Will ich mir nicht angucken.
So, was können wir uns sonst noch anschauen?
Ja, nee.
Nee, es heißt nicht, dass das Video kann tatsächlich nicht angepasst werden.
Das heißt nicht, dass das Video kann tatsächlich nicht angepasst werden.
Keine Ahnung.
Aber manchmal habe ich das Verlangen, Videos nicht anzugucken.
So.
Ich helfe Jugendlichen mit Essstörungen.
Ähm.
Zählt, wenn man zu viel isst, auch als Essstörung?
Was ist denn, Leute?
Ihr keck-weightet so sehr im Chat.
Wollen wir uns sonst, wollen wir uns loslassen?
Neidw 내일.
Neidw.
Ja, okay.
Ja.
wir es uns doch angucken, das Video.
Wenn ihr sagt, ihr wollt das sehen, dann können wir es uns
angucken. Cake Wait.
Nein, nein. Okay.
Ja, dann Cake Waitet doch auch nicht so viel.
Dann Pause Champt eher.
Aber ich glaube, hier geht es nicht
um Leute, die zu dick sind, sondern eher
Leute, die was essen und dann erstmal
aufs Klo gehen, kotzen.
Jetzt steht der Kuchen vor ihnen.
Was geht ihnen durch den Kopf? Ganz einfach.
Was soll mir durch den Kopf gehen?
Wenn es so aussieht, als würde es schmecken,
dann würde ich ihn jetzt einfach futtern.
Was geht ihnen durch den Kopf?
Das ist auch so eine typische
Psychologenfrage, Alter.
Der Label Champ ist noch nicht
done, ne?
Das ist so eine typische
Psychologenfrage.
Wie geht es ihnen dabei?
Monte Reaction
schauen, ne.
Jetzt nicht.
So. Crazy New Storage.
Open
Ah, das wollte ich mir angucken.
Irgendein Typ hat
anscheinend einen
Mähroboter,
heißt das glaube ich korrekterweise,
umgebaut
mit einem Raspberry Pi oder sowas.
Das wollte ich mir mal angucken.
Wahrscheinlich werde ich sowas nicht in meinen Garten
packen, weil
mein Garten ist viel zu unordentlich,
dort irgendeinen Mähroboter
robotieren zu lassen.
Schauen wir mal,
wie der das gebaut hat.
Aha, nur nach 15 Generic Intro Musik
massakriert von seinem
eigenen Mähroboter. Das wäre
tatsächlich irgendeine Story von irgendeinem
billigen Splatterfilm, ja.
Mähroboter
des Grauens
oder irgendwie.
Mähroboter
der Horror in meinem Garten oder irgendwie sowas.
Final Destination
69.
Mähroboter der Verdammnis.
Das ist auch nicht schlecht.
Mich würde ja mal interessieren,
hat er das hinbekommen mit
Kabeln oder geht das
irgendwie über GPS oder so?
Das ist was, was mich bei Mährobotern immer
abgeschreckt hat, dass man irgendwelche Kabel
im Garten verlegen muss.
Wobei
GPS halt so eine Sache ist.
GPS ist halt eigentlich
nicht
genau dafür.
Achso, Chittleshit GPS.
Gut, dass wir drüber
gesprochen haben.
Eigentlich ist
GPS,
nicht zentimetergenau,
zumindest die zivile Version.
Okay, schauen wir mal.
Dr. Fresher, moin.
Wie machen die das eigentlich, die Mähroboter?
Ähm,
haben die einen Behälter?
Dann werden die ja
instant voll. Oder
lassen die das Gemähte einfach
auf dem Gras liegen?
Und wenn die das
liegen lassen, muss man
das danach noch zusammenrechen?
Oder,
ähm,
oder
verwest das dann mit der Zeit,
weil man immer nur ein bisschen
schneidet.
Okay.
Das despawned. Achso.
Logisch.
Schauen wir mal, wie er das gebaut hat.
Hallo.
Ist das ein Deutscher?
Dieser Chat ist jetzt deutsch.
Boundary of your lawn rotate for some time and repeat the whole process until the battery is dead and they need to follow the perimeter wire back into the docking station.
I thought to myself, let's improve on this.
So the open project here was born.
The open mower is able to localize itself using very precise RTK GPS and therefore is able to mow the same area very efficiently.
Was für?
Not only me.
Was für adn GPS?
can mow the same area as this project here, who was born.
The open mower is able to localize itself using very precise RTK GPS and therefore using multiple LAN
What, R B S T A E R ?
Was für an Ding.
Echtzeit kinematik,
Alter, Feif med nennt den Begriff profitable plus The kind of way zebra,
die Echtzeit kinematik ist in der Ge Sister值,
eine Verfahren zur präzisen
Bestimmung von Positionskeule
mit dem Satellitnavigationssystem.
Ich habe keine Ahnung,
was die mir damit sagen wollten.
Geodäsie. Das ist doch irgendwie
Längen- und Breitenkreise. Also das ist irgendwie so...
Ach, keine Ahnung.
Erd-Land-Verteilung.
Ja, keine Ahnung.
Die erste ist die Referenz
an die zweite, der Rover,
dessen Position durch 3D...
Dabei werden Genauigkeiten von 1 bis
2 Zentimeter.
Das ist ziemlich gut.
Damit kann man Rasen mähen, ja.
Die machen das irgendwie so,
dass die von der Basisstation
eine Antenne haben und auf dem Roboter
eine Antenne haben und dann irgendwie
das darüber...
Tatsächlich, ja.
Aha.
Vielleicht kann man dann die Ungenauigkeiten
irgendwie rausrechnen, wenn man
beides empfängt.
Das ist auf jeden Fall Pfeifett-Kram.
Das ist
wirklich nur für
wahnsinnig intelligente Leute.
Gibt es
ESP
2.30 RTK
GPS? Okay.
Gibt es?
So, jetzt erstmal gucken, wie der das
gebaut hat.
German Efficiency.
Das ist ja schon
international so das richtige Meme, ja.
Die tun immer so, als sind wir hier in Deutschland.
Super effizient und super genau
und sonst was. Die waren alle noch nicht hier.
Also ich meine, wir mögen
vielleicht in vielen
Sachen übergenau sein, aber
effizient würde ich mal
bezweifeln, dass wir mit unserer Bürokratie
wahnsinnig effizient
sind. Ich meine, wenn man sich
jetzt zum Beispiel nimmt,
keine Ahnung, ich kann mich
noch dran erinnern,
zum Beispiel, als ich in der Türkei mal im Urlaub war,
wenn da ein Bus gekommen ist,
dann war das eher so,
nice to have, wenn der Bus
innerhalb
des Tages, wo er auf dem Plan steht, auch kommt
oder sowas, ja. Also natürlich,
man kann sich immer noch negativ
Beispiele nehmen, wo alles noch
schlechter funktioniert, aber die sollen sich mal
die Bahn angucken und sowas, ja.
Das finde ich gut.
Also das finde ich schon mal richtig gut.
Ganz ehrlich, diese Sachen mit Kabel
legen, finde ich richtig hängen geblieben.
Ohne Kabel würde ich mir
sowas vielleicht
auch mal überlegen.
Wobei ich glaube, das funktioniert nur mit Garten,
wo glatt ist, ne.
Bei mir ist auch mal die eine oder andere
Wurzel im Weg von einem Baum.
Ich glaube, damit funktioniert das
nicht richtig.
Ratok sagt,
durchlaufe gerade UK-Visa,
ist genauso schlimm mit Bürokratie, okay.
Tja,
genauso schlimm bedeutet ja dann aber auch,
man könnte da einiges
verbessern, auch bei uns.
Ich meine, wenn ich mir überlege,
was du in Deutschland teilweise
machen willst, wenn du eine Firma gründen willst
und wenn du irgendwas rausbringen willst an Produkten,
da wundert mich nicht, dass viele Leute
sagen, ja okay, wir designen das,
vielleicht hier, aber produzieren
lassen, tun wir das dann irgendwie in
China, Vietnam oder sonst wo.
Hier ist ja teilweise
absoluter Wahnsinn, was du machen musst.
Mich fuckt's
übelst ab, dass ich Zwangsmitglied sein
muss in der IHK zum Beispiel.
Ich muss der IHK regelmäßig Geld
überweisen, nur weil ich
ein Gewerbe angemeldet
hab.
Es hat keinen Sinn. Es bringt
mir nichts. Ich will nichts von
dem. Es kostet einfach nur Geld.
Aber ich muss es machen.
So, kommen wir uns mal an.
Wie viel weiß ich gerade aus dem Kopf?
Nicht so viel, 50 Euro oder so.
Und auch, ich glaube auch nur im Jahr
oder im halben Jahr oder irgendwie sowas.
Ich weiß es gar nicht.
Ich glaube 50 Euro. Es ist nicht viel, aber
doch, doch, ich habe einen Vorteil davon.
Ich bekomme regelmäßig
die IHK-Woche oder wie diese
wie dieser
IHK-Zeitschrift. Ich weiß
gar nicht, wie dieses Ding heißt. Ich schmeiß das immer weg.
Ich bekomme regelmäßig das IHK-Magazin.
Jawoll!
Das brauch ich aber.
Ganz wichtig.
Das wandert immer direkt in Müll. Das kommt
gar nicht in die Wohnung mit rein.
Ne, ich bin nicht unter 6.000 Euro Umsatz.
Ich muss bezahlen.
This is done by driving the robot
around the area using a remote control.
Hier you can see my...
Ach, es ist Millionär.
Schön wär's.
Ganz ehrlich, Leute, wenn ich Millionär wäre,
wisst ihr, was ich ändern würde
an meinem Leben?
Soll ich euch sagen?
Was würde ich anders machen, wenn ich Millionär wäre?
Gar nichts. Korrekt.
Ich würde wahrscheinlich
gar nichts anders machen.
Twitter kaufen.
Da müsste ich aber schon ziemlich krasser
Millionär sein.
Drei Tage in der Woche
arbeiten. Das vielleicht.
Aber im Großen und Ganzen würde ich wahrscheinlich
gar nichts machen. Also gar nichts ändern.
Das sieht man nämlich schon daran,
dass mein Kontostand
am Ende des Monats nicht plus minus null ist.
Also es ist jetzt nicht so,
dass ich nicht hinkommen würde.
Und es ist auch nicht so, als dass ich mir...
Dass mein Kontostand
am Ende des Monats nicht plus minus null ist.
Also es ist jetzt nicht so,
dass ich nicht hinkommen würde.
Und es ist auch nicht so, als dass ich mir irgendwelche Sachen,
wo ich sage, oh, das wollte ich schon immer mal machen oder so,
dass ich das nicht mache,
weil ich zu wenig Geld habe oder so.
Es ist...
Ich komme echt gut klar
mit dem, wie es aktuell ist.
Und deswegen...
Doch, ich weiß, was ich machen würde.
Ich würde mir noch mehr Stonks kaufen.
Dass aus dem Geld noch mehr Geld wird.
Tja, das ist ja schön.
Für alle, die nichts bezahlen müssen.
Ich könnte mir endlich
Raspberry Pis leisten. Das ist richtig.
Ja, das hat ja Elon Musk wohl schon gesagt.
Er möchte, dass...
Die sollen weniger Geld bekommen, die Twitter-Chefs.
Das...
Würdest du vielleicht...
Definitiv, das würde ich tatsächlich machen, ja.
Also wenn ich wirklich jetzt ein paar Millionen hätte,
ich würde auf jeden Fall mehr spenden.
Aber ich sage euch,
ich habe das schon oft gesagt,
ihr wisst, dass ich...
Ich habe vergessen, wie sich das nennt.
Ich mag...
Ich kann anderen Menschen nicht so viel abgewinnen.
Also ich würde nicht für soziale Projekte spenden.
Also nicht für soziale Projekte,
die was mit Menschen zu tun haben.
Ich würde für unser Tierheim spenden.
Oder...
Oder für sowas in der Richtung, ja.
Aber ich würde
nicht für Menschen spenden.
Juckt mich nicht.
Aber ich würde tatsächlich mehr spenden,
wenn ich... Also hätte ich jetzt wirklich
5 Millionen oder so.
Vielleicht, vielleicht,
vielleicht würde ich mir auch...
Würde ich mir auch ein anderes Auto
als dem Opel Agila holen.
Einfach nur, weil es geht.
Ich würde...
Ja, ich würde auf jeden Fall
mehr spenden. Aber nicht
an irgendwelche humanitären
sozialen Projekte.
Wobei Tierheime sind ja auch was Soziales.
Aber nix Humanitäres. Das geht mir am Arsch vorbei.
Aber ich würde für Tierheime
spenden oder für irgendwie
für die Tierhilfe oder so
so Dinger. Das ist mir
deutlich lieber.
Bau doch nen Park. Vielleicht würde ich auch nen Park bauen.
Keine Ahnung. Aber wozu?
Den Max-FPS-Park
gibt's dann in Frankfurt. Wobei...
Das wär doch was.
Frankfurt-Goethe-Straße
am Park. Das ist der Max-FPS-Park.
Man merkt, dass du jetzt gerade nicht in der Kirche bist.
Warum?
Ich bin nie in der Kirche.
Was ist das eigentlich für ein Nice?
Twitch-Call anstatt am Pock.
Also an die Kirche spenden würde ich definitiv nix.
Ich würde weder an die Kirche spenden, noch an irgendwelche
sozialen, humanitären Sachen was.
Wie gesagt, ich würde höchstens an Tierheime oder sowas spenden.
Mach ich übrigens aktuell auch.
Ich würde höchstens an Tierheime oder sowas spenden.
Ach so, tja.
Selbst...
Ich war nie gläubig.
Ganz ehrlich.
Ich habe...
Das letzte Mal, wo ich in der Kirche war...
Das war...
Keine Ahnung, da war ich...
Wann macht man Kommunion?
Mit 10 oder so?
Weiß ich nicht.
Das ist das letzte Mal, wo ich in der Kirche gewesen bin.
Und...
Ich war noch nie gläubig.
Ich bin damals... Wisst ihr, warum ich zur Kommunion...
Alter, muss man gucken.
Alter, Kommunion.
Wann macht man das?
10, 10. Ja, irgendwie mit 10.
Wisst ihr, warum ich...
In die Kirche gegangen bin und Kommunion gemacht habe damals?
Der einzige Grund...
Für Geld, richtig.
Genau.
Einzig und allein für Geld.
So sieht's aus, ja.
Ich habe damals über 1000 Mark gekriegt an Spenden.
Weiß nicht, wie man das nennt.
Aber...
Die gesamte Verwandtschaft hat was dagelassen.
Und da kam ich mir mega reich vor damals.
Ja, richtig.
Mark war das noch. Boomer.
Ich bin 1984 geboren.
Man kann sich das vielleicht nicht vorstellen.
Ich glaube, ich bin ein richtig...
Keine Ahnung.
Ein...
Richtig wirrer Hybrid
aus Boomer und Zoomer.
Also ich bin vom Alter her Boomer.
Und von vielen Sachen so...
Die man so über die Jahre mitgenommen hat.
Auch irgendwie Boomer.
Aber auf der anderen Seite...
Was Twitch, Streaming und irgendwie...
Irgendwelche neuen Memes und sowas angeht.
Bin ich Zoomer.
Also ich bin quasi ein...
Weiß ich nicht, ob es dafür ein Wort gibt.
Hybrid-Zoomer oder so.
Heute ist alles ab 30 Boomer.
Ja, hättest du mal besser gemacht.
Also wie gesagt, das ist der einzige Grund,
warum ich damals Kommunion gemacht habe in der Kirche.
Weil ich Geld bekommen habe.
Ich war nie gläubig.
Bin ich...
War ich...
Also war ich nicht.
Bin ich aktuell auch nicht.
Und...
Werde ich wahrscheinlich auch nicht sein.
Man weiß ja nie, was passiert.
Ich habe aber keine Schmerzen damit.
Wenn Leute gläubig sind.
Ich bin der Ansicht,
solange mich keiner bekehren möchte,
darf jeder machen, was er will.
Juckt mich auch nicht.
Ja, wenn mir jetzt natürlich einer erzählen will,
so was weiß ich,
die Jesus liebt euch Leute.
Die teilweise am Südbahnhof in Frankfurt rumeiern oder sowas.
Ja, die gehen mir auf den Keks.
Weil jemand lasst mich in Ruhe.
Aber ansonsten ist mir das egal.
Solange mich die Leute in Ruhe lassen.
Ja, weil man ehrlich ist.
Ob ich jetzt an das fliegende Spaghetti-Monster glauben würde,
oder an irgendwie eine der größeren Weltreligionen,
macht im Prinzip keinen Unterschied.
Das ist alles ziemlicher Schwachsinn.
Was aber witzig ist.
Wenn du irgendeinen...
Wenn du irgendeinen strengen Gläubigen fragst,
egal welche Religion er angehört,
ob er an das fliegende Spaghetti-Monster glaubt,
dann sagt er, ha, lol, willst du mich verarschen?
Was eigentlich total bescheuert ist.
Weil so viel anders ist das jetzt gar nicht,
als das, wo er dran glaubt.
Aber gut, das ist natürlich ein Thema,
da kann man sich wahnsinnig
verdreppelig drüber streiten, ja.
Soll jeder glauben, was er will.
Ist mir echt wurscht.
Solange er mich nicht bekehren will.
Glaubst du, dass wir in einer Simulation leben?
Das kann gut sein.
Das kann ich mir durchaus vorstellen.
Ob das so ist?
Tja, schwierig.
Es ist schwierig, innerhalb einer Simulation rauszubekommen,
ob du in einer Simulation lebst.
Keine Ahnung.
Kennst du das?
Oh ja, das kenn ich.
So, wir gucken jetzt aber das Video mal weiter.
Wir wollten immer noch den Mähroboter gucken,
fällt mir gerade ein.
Also, wir sind irgendwie leicht abgeschwiffen.
Ja, ja, Worldstronic.
Ja, ja, ja.
Da hast du recht.
Was ich auch total bescheuert finde.
Du musst dem Mähroboter lernen, wo der Mähroboter sein soll.
Das ist durch das Fahrzeug um die Gegend mit einem Remote-Kontrollen.
Hier kannst du meinen Vater sehen,
der den Mähroboter mit einem Standard-Xbox-Gamepad kontrolliert.
Alter, mach dir die Musik nicht so laut.
Moment, steuere das gerade mit dem...
Alter, das ist ja mal richtig feifert.
Du kannst einfach deinen Monitor mit dem Controller steuern.
Das ist ja mega, das brauche ich.
Moment, wie hat er das gemacht?
Alter, das ist ja mega nice.
Das würde ich sogar mal rasenmähen.
Das ist durch das Fahrzeug um die Gegend mit einem Remote-Kontrollen.
Ah, der merkt sich quasi, der macht da eine Map quasi draus.
Hier kannst du meinen Vater sehen, der den Mähroboter mit einem Standard-Xbox-Gamepad kontrolliert.
Geil.
Porgas.
Aber das ist, dass er sich so eine Map aufbauen kann,
beziehungsweise...
Die Positionsdaten für die Renn...
Ah, das ist cool, das ist cool.
Nicht mal Wireless-Controller, cringe.
Er kann programmieren, aber keine Sound-Levels angleichen.
Ja, da sieht man mal, das sind...
Es hat schon seinen Grund, warum man Informatik oder Mediendesign oder wie auch immer das heißt, studieren kann.
Das Ding braucht unbedingt eine Kamera.
Dann hätte ich...
Also würde das Ding so funktionieren plus Kamera, das wäre richtig nice.
Da könnte ich meinem Roboter beim Rasenmähen zugucken.
Das wäre richtig futuristisch.
Nee, nächstes Projekt mache ich erst mal die Wetterstation.
Das ist richtig cool, die Idee.
Mich würde mal interessieren, wie er das gebaut hat.
Das wird er doch jetzt in zweieinhalb Minuten nicht unterbringen können.
Ah, okay.
Anscheinend doch.
First, it drives around the outline to ensure that it will not cross the perimeter even during...
...during...
Wie genau wäre eigentlich Bluetooth? Gar nicht.
Mit Bluetooth kannst du nicht gescheit Positionen feststellen.
Mit Bluetooth kannst du höchstens Empfangsstärken feststellen und daran ungefähr ableiten,
wie weit du von deiner Basisstation weg bist oder vom...
Aber das bringt dir nix.
Das finde ich ist eine richtig coole Idee.
Ja, ich klicke jetzt Subscribe.
Und die Glocke, und die Glocke.
Leute, ich habe total...
Leute.
Ja, Wahnsinn.
Ich habe ein total schlechtes Verhältnis von Abonnenten zu Glocke bei mir auf YouTube.
Und warum?
Weil ich schon lange auf YouTube aktiv war, bevor es diese Glocke überhaupt gab.
Und den Großteil meiner Abos gemacht habe, bevor es die Glocke gegeben hat.
Und nachträglich hat die Glocke keiner mehr eingeschaltet.
Die Säcke.
Anzeige ist raus.
Disabo.
Alle, alle disabonnieren.
Ich...
Wobei, ich kann die Leute...
Ich kann die Leute gar nicht disabonnen.
Ich glaube, man kann Leute nicht...
Doch bannen kann ich sie.
Deabonniert das auch, wenn man Leute bannt?
Ich ab...
Swiss Shock ist bei mir genau das Gleiche.
Ich habe bei keinem einzigen Channel, wo ich subscribt habe, die Glocke aktiviert.
Diese Musik dabei, die passt so überhaupt nicht.
Aber guckt mal, richtig nice.
Der weicht, der evadet sogar dem Pfosten.
Der weicht nicht aus, der evadet, Leute.
Der dodgt den Pfosten.
Oh, Chatfrage.
Router, Router-Question.
Was ist eigentlich am sinnvollsten?
Einen Mieten bei Telekom mit dem Vertrag, einen billigen Kauf und lieber einen teuren?
Pff, das kommt drauf an, was du machen willst.
Ansonsten, also, wenn du einfach nur ins Internet willst und da irgendwie keine großartigen Ansprüche dran hast, dann behalte den vom Provider.
Wenn du keinen Bock hast, dass dein Provider theoretisch Zugriff hat auf dein internes Netzwerk, was da dran hängt, dann hol dir einen eigenen.
Weil die Provider-Router haben die Provider theoretisch zumindest Firmware-Update-Möglichkeiten und sowas da drauf.
Allein schon das missfällt mir.
Und einen teuren würde ich mir nur kaufen, wenn du auch die Features davon brauchst.
Also, in der Regel reden wir bei sowas im privaten Bereich ja von einer Fritzbox.
Weil du brauchst ja nicht wirklich einen Router, du brauchst ja ein Multifunktionsgerät.
Du brauchst was mit Modem, eventuell je nachdem, was du benutzt.
Du brauchst was mit Deck-Basis-Station.
Du brauchst was mit WLAN, mit einem Switch drinnen, mit Gäste-WLAN.
Also, du brauchst ein Multifunktionsgerät.
Und im Prinzip für den Heimbereich ist eigentlich eine Fritzbox so das Teil, was man da in der Regel hat.
Und jetzt bleibt eigentlich die Frage, genau, DHCP ist aber so Dinger.
Jetzt bleibt ja nur die Frage, billige Fritzbox oder teure Fritzbox?
Das würde ich ganz klar davon abhängig machen, ob du die Features der teuren Fritzbox brauchst.
Wenn nicht, nimm eine billige Fritzbox.
Ich meine, eine teure Fritzbox, ohne dass du die Features verwendest, ist nicht besser als eine billige Fritzbox.
Für das.
Und beispielsweise WLAN-technisch unterscheiden die sich, glaube ich, relativ viel, was die unterstützen.
Sowohl von den Antennen, als auch vom WLAN-Standard und allem.
Aber wenn du das WLAN beispielsweise gar nicht über die Fritzbox benutzen willst, weil du vielleicht Access-Points im Haus verteilt hast,
dann ist das schon mal egal.
Also, ich habe auch eine Fritzbox, kann ich an der Stelle sagen.
Ich habe eine Fritzbox, allerdings so gut wie einzig und allein als Deck-Station.
Für die Telefone.
Ich habe die billigste Fritzbox, die es gibt.
Irgendwie 70 Euro oder so.
Die kleinste, die es gibt.
Und das Einzige, was die macht, ist VoIP.
VoIP und Decked.
Sonst nix.
Ach ja, ich habe noch vier Fritz-Smart Home-Thermostate dran angemeldet.
VoIP, ja doch, die macht VoIP und Decked.
Die Thermostate sind ja auch Decked.
Das ist richtig Boomer-Technologie, ja.
Und das reicht.
Ich habe keinen Grund, mir eine teurere Fritzbox zu kaufen.
Festnetz-Telefone gibt es in diesem Sinn gar nicht mehr.
Es gibt noch historisch quasi so Sachen wie Festnetz-Telefonnummern,
die eigentlich in der heutigen Zeit auch extrem unsinnig sind,
weil das ist alles VoIP.
Und dementsprechend kannst du das auch auf dem Handy empfangen.
Also, ich habe es so gemacht bei mir daheim.
Ich habe meine Telefonnummer, also die Festnetz-Telefonnummer,
die habe ich umgebracht.
Und die habe ich umgezogen mal irgendwann zu Easybell.
Warum?
Weil das ein VoIP-Anbieter ist und ich bezahle da irgendwie 2,99 Euro oder so im Monat
für den VoIP-Anschluss.
Warum?
Weil Telefonnummer portieren bei Anwenderwechseln immer der größte Abfuck überhaupt ist.
Also, das Schlimmste beim Anbieterwechsel, sei es jetzt von Vodafone zur Telekom
oder vielleicht irgendwann mal auch zu Deutsche Glasfaser oder was auch immer,
der größte Abfuck ist immer Telefonnummer portieren.
Deswegen dachte ich mir, ich nehme die Telefonnummer einfach mal aus diesem Spiel mit raus
und portiere die ganz woanders hin.
Und ich habe die damals zu Easybell portieren lassen
und habe da jetzt den allerkleinsten Tarif nur Telefon für irgendwie 2,99 Euro im Monat.
Das reicht mir, dicke.
Und dadurch bin ich unabhängig, was Anbieterwechsel angeht.
Und das ist halt auch diesmal jetzt richtig echtes, komplettes VoIP.
Wie es im Prinzip bei der Telekom und bei Vodafone auch ist.
Nur, dass die immer noch so komische Dinger haben wird, schließt es doch mal an den Router an.
Und sowas, das ist VoIP.
Das bedeutet, ich kann auch ohne Probleme eine x-beliebige VoIP-App oder Zip-App nehmen für mein Smartphone.
Und darüber mit meiner Festnetznummer telefonieren.
Also, wenn ich angerufen werde auf dem Festnetz, dann klingelt auch mein Handy, weil ich dann einen Zip-Client drauf habe.
Also, ich kann...
Wenn ich angerufen werde auf der Festnetz-Telefonnummer, ohne Probleme von unterwegs, das annehmen.
Weil es auch auf dem Handy rauskommt.
Also, Festnetz in dem Sinn ergibt eigentlich keinen Sinn mehr.
Früher hat es noch ein bisschen mehr Sinn ergeben, als du noch richtig echte Kupferleitung von der Telekom hattest,
wo dann auch noch Telefon drüber ging, inklusive Stromversorgung von mindestens einem Telefon und sowas.
Da war das noch ein bisschen was anderes, gerade für Hausnotrufe und sowas.
Aber gibt's ja heute nicht mehr.
Es ist heute alles mehr oder weniger...
Also, ich glaube, es gibt noch ganz, ganz wenige Ausnahmen.
Zum Beispiel, wenn man einen Fahrstuhl hat.
Notrufsysteme im Fahrstuhl, die müssen, glaube ich, noch per richtig echten Festnetzkram angeschlossen werden.
Aber, mal ganz davon abgesehen, spätestens ab der nächsten...
Wie nennt man das?
Ab dem nächsten Knotenpunkt der Telekom ist es e-VoIP.
Also, selbst wenn ihr noch einen oldschool-analogen Telefonanschluss habt, spätestens wenn das bei der nächsten Box von der Telekom ankommt, ist es e-VoIP.
Warum? Decktelefone daheim sind doch gar nicht so schlecht.
Meine Tür-Gegensprecher-Nahe geht auch überdeckt.
Hast du ein VPN zu dir nach Hause?
Nein, hab ich nicht.
Ja, ich hab ne Domain gekauft.
Aber ich benutze kein VPN.
Ich hatte ne ganze Weile auch nen VPN bei mir laufen.
laufen als ich noch pfz am eingang hatte dann auch mit client auf dem iphone und
so aber ich habe festgestellt ich brauche es nicht ich verwende ich
verwende nichts davon also ich habe kein anwendungszweck von unterwegs auf ein
heimnetz zuzugreifen notizen und bilder synchronisiere ich wenn ich daheim im
wlan bin brauche ich nicht brauche ich kein internet vpn gedöns positions
tracking mache ich anderweitig muss ich auch nicht über vpn machen und von
unterwegs in mein heim automatisierung rein zu gucken hat auch wenig sinn
also ich habe festgestellt ich hatte das lange zeit habe es aber eigentlich nie
verwendet deswegen habe ich jetzt kein vpn mehr aber ich habe eigene domain für
meine internetseite
internen kästen habe ich eine ganz billige domain gekauft für glaub drei
euro oder so im jahr oder noch billiger und gut ist kann man das absehen mit zwei
faktor authentifizieren bevor man sich verbindet ja kannst du machen kann man
auch machen ja dass das die möglichkeit gibt ich kenne mich damit aber nicht gut
aus weil ich lange kein vpn mehr betrieben habe
wie machst du das mit dem position tracking
über mqtt ich benutze wie heißt der gramm und rex ios ich habe die app und
sie schickt regelmäßig meine position an einen mqtt server und mein hommel ist
dann ist subscribed an diesen mqtt server der is public der mqtt server
und mein hommel ist dann verbindet sich von intern nach außen hast du auch den
verlauf ja aber halt nur intern bei mir erst mal in der smart home lösung also
ich kann mir theoretisch angucken wo ich gestern gewesen bin aber warum ja aber
würde funktionieren kannst du dein pc zu hause weltweit aus starten per wake
online der läuft auch nicht 24 die mein desktop pc ist nur an wenn ich davor
sitze wozu soll ich den starten du brauchst das für reports bei der
kunde dann ist was anderes ja und sinnvoll das anwendungsgebiet dann kann
man ja auch vpn machen was ich halt sagen wollte ich hatte kein sinnvolles
anwendungsgebiet und man muss nicht sein netz von außen aufmachen wenn man das
nicht braucht also der der beste schutz leute ist immer noch wenn was gar nicht
erst geht und danach abstand aber wenn was gar nicht erst offen ist müsst ihr
euch auch nicht schützen weil es gibt keine verbindungsmöglichkeit ja das mit
signal gescheit ist bei uns aber schwierig auf 2,4 gigahertz wenn ich hier
wlan ich hab mal bin hier mal mit einem
android
android tablet rumgelaufen hat mal gemap wir haben glaube ich 87 oder sowas
fragt mich gar nicht ganz so viel ist es nicht aber es war verdammt billig weiß
es niemals irgendwie keine ahnung 50 oder so 50 60 ist das habe ich hier
gescannt in der nähe haben ist da hier wurden viele leute
nee ob das habe ich hinter mir habe ich aktuell kein anwendungszweck dafür ja
aber das bestimmt auch nur mit verschiedenen sendern dass der dann dass
du dann irgendwie das gebiet absteckt und der das dann quasi wieder verprügelt ist deines schatzes.
sie sich errechnet aus empfangsstärke von unterschiedlichen sendern oder so
was weil sie nicht ich habe bekommt meine telefonnummer portieren zwar gar
kein problem weil ich gar kein vpn braucht warum soll ich den vpn benutzen
wenn ich kein vpn brauche kann man so eine sim telefonnummer kaufen bei deinem
mobilfunkanbieter nutzen also wenn man einen anruf auf dem handy bekommt dass
man dem rechner dass man auch am rechner abheben kann ja du brauchst ein
zip client das hat mit dem handy nichts zu tun
du bekommst eine zip und du bekommst eine telefonnummer von einem anbieter
und du bekommst zugangsdaten für einen zip client und die zip client oder zip
clients durch den kannst du deine fritzbox kann das machen dein handy kann
das machen dein desktop pc kann das machen überall wo du einen x-beliebigen
voip client installieren kannst
ja ja kannst du machen also ich habe ich habe ground war ja offen auf dem
iphone round round war ja app ios also ich habe das ding als voip app und da
habe ich da ruft mich übrigens erwin schrödinger auch öfters macht das bild
aller und da kriege ich dann ein anruf aufs handy wenn mich einer auf dem
festnetz anruft und ich könnte ohne probleme
und ich könnte ohne probleme auch in einen x-beliebigen zip client für windows
installieren mich darüber anrufen lassen oder für oder linux oder mac oder so
überhaupt kein ding das funktioniert das heißt das musst du auch nicht bei
dem mobilfunkanbieter nutzen du hast ja mobiles internet und darüber läuft das
dann das hat mit dem mobilfunkanbieter wenig zu tun
hauptsache was mobiles internet oder wlan oder so beobachtet ort schick wird panik
kriegen, wenn da so ein Rasenmäher rumläuft.
Im Garten.
Oder was rumläuft, oder rumfährt.
Das ist richtig. VPN sind
in der Regel Kleinzertifikate und dann brauchst
du eigentlich auch keine Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung.
Aber,
wenn man sich sicherer fühlt,
kann man das machen.
Ich meine, Passwort und Zertifikat
sind ja schon Zwei-Faktor-Authentifizierung,
aber wenn man kein Passwort will,
gibt bestimmt die Möglichkeit bei WireGuard
auch irgendwie sowas wie
SMS-Authentifizierung zu machen oder
irgendeinen Authentifizierung-Server einzubinden,
der das dann für dich macht. Gibt's bestimmt,
hab ich noch nie ausprobiert, ist aber eine gute Projektidee.
Das ist eigentlich
äh,
VPN mit
SMS, FUFA
oder Aus-App oder sowas.
Das muss man mal ausprobieren.
Ich muss meinen PC nicht
von unterwegs starten. Mein Desktop-PC
ist ein Desktop-PC, warum sollte ich den von unterwegs
starten? Aber, wie gesagt,
ich erkenne ja an, dass jeder unterschiedliche
Anwendungsgebiete hat.
So, jetzt müssen wir aber endlich mal weitergucken,
was der Rasenmäher hier macht.
Wir brauchen ihn wieder ewig für das Video.
Das ist wirklich so...
Diese Musik, ne?
Ich weiß nicht, wo die herkommt,
aber die hörst du so oft,
das muss irgendwie so eine
Royalty-Free
Hinter-Background-Music
Stock-Music
sein.
...
500.
Äh,
wie schreibt man, wie schreibt man Mower?
Mo-Mo-Mover.
Mover.
Yard-Force.
Oh, ordentlich.
Also, wenn ich eh schon im Garten bin.
Naja, gut.
Es zieht einfach immer, dass die Leute
...
menschen auf denen auf diesen werbefotos haben vpn heide doch wenigstens das tls
kleins server
was vpn heidet erste margonix vpn ist auf also du hast du hast dann nicht mehr
deine deine ip vom handy die der web server sieht sondern der sieht dann halt
deine externe ip von daheim wenn du über den vpn gehst was sie was die jetzt
einen vpn mit irgendeiner tls verbindung zum server zu tun hat das verstehe ich
nicht weil die tls verbindung machst du immer noch von deinem endgerät zum server
hin hat dann egal ob über vpn oder nicht ja gut du kannst wenn du so willst du
kannst anonymer surfen dahingehend
dass du ja schlechter zu tracken bist vielleicht ja dass jetzt irgendein
anbieter nicht mehr sagen kann okay hier ist er jetzt mobil unterwegs oder hier
hat er jetzt diese ip ist befindet sich irgendwo in frankfurt oder so das
könnte du könntest das mit dem vpn vielleicht das tracking ein bisschen
erschweren aber jetzt nicht wirklich großartig ich meine dann sieht er wie
gesagt deine ip von daheim anstatt seine eine handy ip aber ansonsten ändert vpn
einen tracking relativ wenig das ist ja auch das was die vpn-anbieter immer
erzählen was schwachsinn ist ein vpn schützt dich null davor getrackt zu
werden oder nicht du kannst du kannst wenn du getrackt wirst also wenn wenn
ihnen anbieter der meinung ist er möchte jetzt nachvollziehen was denn so die
leute die seine webseite verwenden machen dann schützt dich ein vpn nicht
davor du hast dann vielleicht eine andere
absender ip oder sowas aber das tracking läuft doch zum kredit zum größten
Teil eh über irgendwelche Fingerprints von deinem Browser oder wenn du Cookies und Sachen aktiviert hast, da drüber, da wirst du auch nicht weniger getrackt.
Oh, ich wurde geradet. MonkaS, die Raspberry Pi Cloud.
Hey, von dir hab ich, dass der Name, ich hab letztens ein Video von dir geguckt auf YouTube, wo du dich übelst aufgeregt hast über Unify.
Falls du das bist.
Und das fand ich gut, weil ich reg mich auch über Unify auf.
Ich reg mich auch in letzter Zeit über Unify auf.
Wobei ich sagen muss, inhaltlich würde ich sagen, war ich nicht ganz d'accord mit dem Inhalt des Videos, aber den Punkt sich aufregen über Unify, das konnte ich nachvollziehen, ja.
Ja, aber nochmal zurück zu dieser VPN-Geschichte.
Also, die VPN-Anbieter versprechen...
...einfach viel, aber das ist alles nur die halbe Wahrheit zum größten Teil.
Weil deine Absender-IP ist dann halt die vom VPN-Anbieter oder die, wenn du dich unterwegs per VPN daheim einwählst oder so von dir daheim.
Aber das ändert beim Tracking ja nichts.
Wie gesagt, das Tracking funktioniert ja in den seltensten Fällen noch, also wenn du es mit dem Browser machst, über irgendwelche, über die Absender-IP oder sowas.
Das ist ja Oldschool-Noob-Tracking.
Getrackt wird über irgendwelche anderen Sachen, die dein Browser aus...
...auszeichnet, ja.
Irgendwelche, was beispielsweise im Browser relativ beliebt war, um festzustellen, ob es ein Unique-User ist, ist Schriftarten.
Wobei das mittlerweile nicht mehr so einfach geht.
Der neueste Trend, was Browser-Fingerprinting angeht, habe ich gelesen, ist Canvas.
Genau, genau, 109305, genau, Canvas ist der neueste Trend.
Und wisst ihr, das muss ich euch jetzt mal erzählen, das ist wirklich Massive-Fivehead.
Also das ist wirklich so high IQ.
Da musst du erst mal drauf kommen.
Wisst ihr, was die machen, um festzustellen...
Also, ich muss das noch mal kurz, äh, kurz, kurzartig, ähm...
Ja, aber Fingerprinting ist wichtig fürs Tracking.
Ähm...
Ich muss das noch mal kurz, kurz erklären.
Also, wenn du als Anbieter feststellen möchtest, ob beispielsweise ein spezieller User, äh, was weiß ich, äh...
Immer der, ob dich immer wieder der gleiche User besucht, ist jetzt ja auch erst mal egal.
Dann musst du den User...
Ja, irgendwie identifizieren können.
Du kannst es über seine Absender-IP machen, das ist aber nicht so schön.
Am besten wäre, du kannst das Browser-spezifisch tracken.
Das heißt, du müsstest jetzt irgendwie rausbekommen, welches...
Welche Eigenheiten der Browser hat, deiner Benutzer, um sie möglichst eindeutig identifizieren zu können.
Und wenn nicht eindeutig, dann vielleicht zumindest Gruppen identifizieren zu können.
Und sei es auch nur, um ihnen besser Produkte zu empfehlen.
So.
Und Canvas ist eine richtig coole Geschichte.
Ich habe mal eine Frage an euch, Chat.
Was, mal angenommen, ich möchte jetzt als Anbieter erkennen, welches Betriebssystem ihr verwendet.
Oder mit welchem Gerät ihr euch...
Mit welchem Gerät ihr meine Webseite verwendet.
So.
Und ihr teilt mir das nicht mit.
Ihr teilt mir das nicht mit.
Also, ihr habt keinen Client-String oder sonst was im Browser.
Also, ihr wollt gar nicht, dass ich das mitbekomme.
Was könnt ihr machen?
Fonts.
Ja, Fonts ist das eine.
Font-Rendering ist das andere.
Font-Rendering.
Und wisst ihr was?
Und wisst ihr, was beliebt ist?
Emojis.
Wenn ich ein Emoji-Render und danach gucke, wie das Emoji aussieht, weiß ich, auf welcher Plattform ihr unterwegs seid.
Weil iOS-Emojis sehen anders aus als Android-Emojis, sehen anders aus als Windows-Emojis, sehen anders aus als Samsung- oder sonst was Emojis.
Das heißt, die machen ein...
Ganz easy gesagt.
Die machen ein verstecktes...
Canvas auf ihrer Webseite, malen ein Emoji da rein, was dann der Font-Renderer vom jeweiligen Browser auf diesem jeweiligen Betriebssystem macht.
Und danach gucken sie sich das Canvas an und schauen, welches Emoji wurde denn gemalt.
Und wenn es ein iOS-Emoji ist, wissen sie, aha, ist wohl ein iOS-Safari-Benutzer.
Es gibt ja unter iOS prinzipiell nur Safari.
Wenn du ein Android-Emoji hast, sehen sie, aha, guck mal, das ist ein Android-Emoji.
Das ist eigentlich richtig pfeifert.
Und es gibt noch mehr Möglichkeiten.
Zum Beispiel kannst du sogar relativ gut, habe ich letztens was drüber gelesen, feststellen, was für Hardware-Ausstattung der PC hat.
Weil du kannst einfach gucken, wie schnell kann der bestimmte Sachen malen.
Ja, du machst einfach Berechnungen, die CPU-intensiv sind, du machst vielleicht kurze Berechnungen, die GPU-intensiv sind.
Sei es über WebGL oder sonst was, was malen im Hintergrund.
Und daran kannst du relativ gut feststellen, was für eine Hardware-Ausstattung der PC hat.
Und das alles wohlgemerkt ohne...
Das ist der Client-Browser, der dir das mitteilt.
Das ist eigentlich richtig, richtig Big Brain, ja.
Ich weiß gar nicht, wie wir da jetzt drauf gekommen sind.
Aber da schütze ich den VPN nicht davor.
Genau, davon hatten wir es.
Ja, genau.
Und wenn du das in Kombination machst, Auflösung, Canvas-Geschichten, Rendergeschwindigkeit, Font-Rendering,
dann hast du einen ziemlich guten Fingerprint.
Also quasi so Kombination aus allem.
Ist relativ einzigartig.
Dann pro User.
Das heißt, du kannst Leute tracken.
Aktivierte, deaktivierte Features, genau.
Du kannst quasi Leute tracken, obwohl sie nicht wollen, dass du sie trackst.
Und da hilft dir ein VPN absolut gar nichts gegen.
VPN hilft dir übrigens auch nicht, dass das Ganze sicherer wird.
Weil das Einzige, was bei einem VPN zusätzlich verschlüsselt ist, ist der Weg von dir zum VPN.
Aber der Weg vom VPN zum Server, auf den du...
Du willst, weil da die Webseite liegt, ist, wenn es unverschlüsselt ist, genauso unverschlüsselt wie vorher.
Also eigentlich bringt VPN in 95% der Fällen nicht das, was die VPN-Anbieter versprechen.
Wofür es was bringt, wofür es was bringt, ist, wenn man sich zum Beispiel Sicherheitskopien runterladen möchte.
Über Torrent oder sowas.
Was wir natürlich alle nicht machen.
Oder wenn...
Wenn man zum Beispiel über offenes...
Ja, SwissShock, ja.
Wenn man über ein offenes WLAN zum Beispiel ins Internet geht, wo jeder x-beliebige Dude, der da mit dem Notebook rumsitzt, mitlesen könnte.
Dann ist das sinnvoll, über ein VPN zu gehen.
Aber das machen die meisten Leute nicht.
Die meisten Leute verwenden VPN nicht dafür.
Die meisten Leute verwenden VPN, weil irgendein YouTuber in seinem YouTube-Video erzählt hat,
mit VPN-Anbieter XY ist das alles viel mehr Privacy und viel sicherer und viel, viel besser.
Ja.
Obwohl es das eigentlich gar nicht ist für die meisten Anwendungszwecke.
Jetzt hätten wir das auch.
Jetzt können wir eigentlich das Video mit dem Rasenmäher endlich weitergucken.
Ich habe es ewig gebraucht, aber...
Gut, ich weiß nicht, wie wir jetzt von Rasenmäher auf VPN und Browser gekommen sind, aber immerhin.
Man muss...
Ich bin ja Meister des Side-Trackings.
Ja, man kann JavaScript deaktivieren, das ist wahr, aber mit deaktiviertem JavaScript funktioniert halt das Internet heutzutage nicht mehr.
Oder...
Das Internet ist jetzt natürlich auch technisch nicht mehr da.
Technisch gesehen falsch.
Die Webseiten funktionieren heute halt nicht mehr ohne JavaScript.
Leute.
Kennt noch jemand?
Kennt noch jemand den alten Netscape Navigator?
Wo wir gerade bei solchen...
Was ist denn das für eine Bildauflösung, Alter?
Was zum Teufel ist das?
Ein größeres Bild ging nicht, oder was?
Gut, 640x480 war vielleicht damals angesagt.
Ja, das hatte damals sogar schon ein HTML-Editor, der besser als Frontpage war.
Ja.
Kann man sich aber nicht darauf verlassen.
Ja, dafür ist es sinnvoll.
Ja, Tor ist halt für File-Sharing weniger zu gebrauchen.
Natürlich nur für Linux-Distribution, ja?
Oder Sicherheitskopien.
Nein, habe ich nicht.
Habe ich mich am Anfang des Streams lang drüber ausgelassen.
Will ich jetzt nicht nochmal alles erzählen.
Du meinst SSL, nicht SSH, oder?
Gut, ähm...
Gucken wir uns das Video jetzt weiter an.
Gibt es einen Unterschied per SSL und TLS?
Das ist eine gute Frage.
Ich glaube...
Ich glaube nicht.
Ähm...
Das eine ist...
Lass mich mal überlegen.
Also, SSL ist TLS.
So viel ist klar.
Wobei ich mir nicht sicher bin,
ob sich SSL nicht mit TLS verbindet.
Ob sich SSL nicht vielleicht auf eine Spezialvariante von TLS bezieht.
Ach, so war das, genau.
Ja, gut.
Ja, dann passt das.
Dann passt das, ja.
SSL 3, TLS 1.0.
Sind wir nicht bei 1.2 mittlerweile schon?
Du bist im Livestream.
Ja, du bist hier unten irgendwo, ne?
Oder 1.3 sogar schon.
Also könnte man auch TLS...
Ja, könnte man sagen.
Wobei, korrekterweise eigentlich nicht das, sondern...
Oh, wie heißt dieser Zertifikat an...
Äh, Zertifikatstelle?
X509, müsstest du eigentlich sagen.
Wobei das niemand sagt.
Die Chinesen haben TLS 1.3 eine Zeit lang blockiert.
Die Chinesen blockieren ziemlich viel.
Vor allem übrigens auch gerade den Hafen in Shanghai, habe ich gehört.
Was macht eigentlich der Shanghai-Hafen?
Kann man wieder bei AliExpress bestellen?
Oder sind die China-Chinesen immer noch dabei und sagen,
wir lassen keine Schiffe rein?
Ich weiß nicht.
Ich habe keine Schiffe rein.
Hafen von Shanghai.
Staut sich da immer noch.
Stau. Stau.
Weiß nicht, ob das immer noch so ist.
Gut, jetzt gucken wir aber endlich mal das Video weiter.
Kann nicht sein, dass ich dann wieder 3 Stunden für brauche,
um ein 5-Minuten-Video über den Mähroboter zu sehen.
So, wir fangen jetzt hier an der Stelle nochmal an,
dass er uns erklären kann,
wie er die Hardware
von seinem GPS-getrackten
Mähroboter zusammen
gewurstelt hat.
A space for this project
I'm using an off-the-shelf robotic mower.
This is because you get most components in a neat package for around 400 euros.
You get the main mowing motor and the two drive motors with encoders on it,
as well as a battery and a waterproof sturdy enclosure.
Aber wie hat er denn jetzt das?
Ich meine, der muss den ja irgendwie smart gemacht haben mit einem Raspberry Pi oder einem ESP oder wie?
Cheaper than buying the components individually.
All electronics inside are replaced by custom ones.
And the designs are of course open source in the OpenMall project.
This mower is very hacker-friendly because all electronics are connected using standard...
Hey, das ist so ein Standard-ATX-Stecker.
Das finde ich schon mal gut, dass sie da nicht irgendwie welche...
dass sie nicht so China-Style-Kram machen,
wo danach erstmal Kunstharz über das Board gekippt wird oder sowas.
...using standard Molex-Connectors.
But now let's look at the custom hardware.
The main processing is done by a Raspberry Pi 4.
It runs the larger part of the OpenMall-Software, for example navigation and localization.
All real-time tasks are handled by the small Raspberry Pi Pico microcontroller,
which is located below the...
Warum hat er denn da zwei?
Ja gut, der Raspberry Pi ist zum Steuern von...
...Stepper-Motoren und so, glaube ich, nicht so geil, aber das...
Warum hat er denn da zwei?
Man, genug Rechenleistung hat der Pi auf jeden Fall, ja.
...RTK-GPS-Board.
The three motors are controlled using three XESC-Motor-Controllers.
Those are also an open source project of mine.
They are also some...
Boah, also, das machst du wirklich nicht von heute auf morgen.
Ich hab gedacht, das ist ein easy mod.
Der pappt da jetzt ein Raspberry Pi 4 mit GPS-Modul rein...
...und...
...so gut ist, dass es tatsächlich deutlich komplizierter, als ich mir das jetzt erstmal vorgestellt hab.
...some connectors for emergency stops and a user interface, as well as a sound module.
Ich mein, da ist ja von dem ursprünglichen Board kaum noch was übrig.
...fits in the original shell, and so the buttons can be used as expected.
If you want to build your own open Mower, check out the...
Da ist nichts mehr vom Originalen drin.
Boah, okay, das ist natürlich nicht...
...so einfach.
...mal nebenbei gemacht.
Ich zeig mal hier, Projekte, GitHub.
Boah, bisschen gedudelt.
Ähm...
2,6K, das ist schon sehr nice.
ROS.
Soll das Real-Time Operating System sein.
EFU A100...
Ich glaube, niemand, der sich dieses Projekt anschaut, ist 100% sicher, was er macht.
Wie denn auch, er hat es ja vorher noch nie gemacht.
Intro-Video.
Okay, das ist...
...da bist du einen Monat mit beschäftigt, bis das funktioniert.
Das ist eher was...
Ich glaube, das ist eher was, wenn man halt Bock hat, mal längerfristig was zu basteln.
Weniger als wenn man nen...
Also...
Wenn man jetzt sagt, man möchte nen...
...Mähroboter haben, der halt einfach funktionieren soll.
Besser, besser heute als morgen, dann ist das Projekt wahrscheinlich...
...nicht das.
Das ist, glaube ich, eher was, wenn man sagt, ich möchte hauptsächlich ein Bastelprojekt haben.
Und am Ende kommt vielleicht ein funktionierender Mähroboter.
Raus.
Dann hier, das ist ein Spannungswandler, hat er hier.
Und das ist ein...
Das ist der GPS-Sensor vielleicht?
Ist das hier GPS?
Oder was meint ihr?
Oder ist das Beschleunigungssensor oder sowas?
Soundmodule!
Kann auch was sagen, dann.
Okay, da hast du was zu tun.
Da hast du was zu tun, bis du das gebaut hast.
Hoffentlich nicht C++.
Ihhh, C++!
Pff.
War ja klar.
Na gut, was sonst, ja.
Sei es jetzt, ob es irgendwelches Arduino-kompatibles Zeug ist, oder sonst ist es alles letztendlich C++.
Ist zwar abfuckhoch 10, aber kommst du nicht drumherum.
Ja, also bis du das gebaut hast, hast du echt was zu tun.
Aber, coole Idee.
Kennst du dich mit LoRaWan aus?
Ja, wir haben sogar mal LoRa-Sachen gebaut im Stream vor...
...Jahren?
Weiß ich nicht.
LoRa?
Low-Level-Zeugs.
Und 1,5 Kilometer Datenübertragung, ESP32, Wassersensor, Wifi, LoRa.
Ja, haben wir hier gemacht.
Guck da, Zeug.
Zeug haben wir da gemacht.
Easy.
Den habe ich aber nicht im Einsatz gehabt, den Sensor.
Warum sind die LoRa-Gateways so teuer?
Ähm.
Weil das, oh wie hieß der Kram, Multi-Channel-Gateways oder sowas sind.
Du brauchst aber nicht unbedingt...
...einen Gateway.
Du kannst auch irgendeinen, äh, ESP32 nehmen, mit, äh, einem LoRa-Modul.
Da musst du halt selbst basteln.
Das ist richtig.
Das, das ist richtig.
LoRa ist das eigentliche Protokoll.
Also das, das Low-Level, äh, was ist das dann?
Layer, Layer 1 und 2 Übertragung.
Hm, hm, hm, stimmt.
Ähm, und wenn du so Sachen wie TT, äh, wie heißt das Ding?
TTN?
TTN heißt es, glaube ich.
Machen willst.
Dann...
Dann musst du noch ein bisschen mehr basteln.
Ey, du kannst mich was fragen.
Es ist jetzt aber nicht so, als hätte ich damit wahnsinnig viel gemacht, ja?
Also frag ruhig.
Ich hab, äh, was ich gemacht habe, ist...
Ich hab, äh, äh, Empfänger gebaut.
Und, ähm, also, äh, statt, äh, LoRa-Ding, was ich bei mir daheim stellen kann, was Daten empfängt.
Und ich hab nen Bodenfeuchtigkeitssensor gebaut mit nem Low-Power-ESP32 dran, der zum größten Teil im Deep Sleep ist.
Und dreimal am Tag aufwacht.
Und den, äh, äh, Feuchtigkeit vom, vom, vom Bo-, also Widerstand vom Boden, wo man die Bodenfeuchtigkeit daraus ableiten kann, heimsendet.
Das hab ich gebaut.
Das hat auch funktioniert, aber ich hab's am Endeffekt nie verwendet.
Ja. Wisst ihr, wofür das gedacht war?
Ich glaube, ich hab das schon öfters erzählt, aber sind jetzt ein paar neue Leute dabei.
Das war ursprünglich dafür gedacht, dass ich im Sommer weiß, wann ich auf den Friedhof fahren muss.
Zum Grab von Oma und Opa.
Und gießen muss.
Der Friedhof ist nicht so weit weg und das hat für die Entfernung mit LoRa-Übertragung geklappt.
Da wollte ich eigentlich eine wasserdichte Box nehmen und die nebendran legen und den Bodenfeuchtigkeitssensor in das Grab buddeln.
Und dann konnte mir das Bescheid sagen, wann ich hin muss gießen und wann nicht.
Habe ich aber nie gemacht bisher, also ich habe es da nie wirklich verwendet.
Also, war eher so eine Idee, das zu machen, habe ich aber nie gemacht.
Und, ja, du kannst auch, ja, das geht auch.
Leider kann ich meinen Briefkasten nicht gescheit automatisieren, weil der zu schepp ist.
Max automatisiert den Friedhof.
Naja, buddeln, halt den Bodenfeuchtigkeitssensor da reinstecken, dass du es nicht direkt siehst von außen.
Weil ansonsten, mir haben Leute auf dem Friedhof schon Sachen geklaut.
Es hat mal jemand unsere Gießkanne geklaut auf dem Friedhof.
Es hat mal jemand Blumen geklaut auf dem Friedhof.
Und einmal ist jemand mit einem Reifen über das Grab drüber gefahren.
Da hat irgend...
Da hat irgendein Baggerbuddler auf dem Friedhof nicht aufgepasst oder so.
Also, wer denkt, da passiert nichts...
Ja, die Leute klauen Sachen auf dem Friedhof.
Wer denkt, da passiert nichts, da würde ich mich nicht drauf verlassen.
Als halt Frankfurt und Umgebung.
Aber die haben die Gießkanne...
Also, die Gießkanne war mal weg.
Und es hat mal einer Blumen geklaut.
Ja, aber du musst am Briefkasten irgendwo den Schalter anbringen.
Und bei mir ist die Klappe zu wackelig.
Habe ich mir auch schon überlegt.
So, was gucken wir denn jetzt noch, Leute?
Ich habe zwar Hunger, aber irgendeine Sache gucken wir jetzt noch.
Felbi, danke für den Sub.
Zwölf Monate.
Jetzt hast du zum ersten Mal den Keks mit goldener Halskette erlangt.
Massive.
Mehr gibt es nicht.
Du hast quasi das höchste Achievement unlockt.
ER-Entfernungssensor.
Das habe ich mir auch schon überlegt, ob ich da nicht so etwas reinmachen soll,
dass ich erkenne, wenn Post drin ist, erkennt man das ja.
Aber da bin ich mir nicht so sicher, wie gut das in der Box funktioniert.
Zumal das Problem ist, an einem ER-Entfernungssensor,
den musst du dauerhaft mit Strom versorgen, dass er funktioniert,
im Vergleich zu einem Schalter.
Ein Schalter kann ein ESP oder sowas triggern, das es auslöst.
Ein ER-Sensor muss dauerhaft mit Strom versorgt werden,
was ihn nicht batterietauglich macht.
Oder aber du wachst ab und zu auf, misst die Entfernung und sagst dann Bescheid.
Dann ist es mit ziemlicher Verzögerung.
Und wenn du zu oft aufwachst, verbrauchst du auch zu viel Batterie.
Schwierig, schwierig.
Es ist gar nicht so einfach, sowas zu bauen,
wenn man keinen Briefkasten hat, der so 0815 ist, mit einer schweren Klappe.
Ich krieg keine SMS von der Post, wenn ich was bekomme.
Du brauchst für LoRa nicht unbedingt ein Gateway in dem Sinn.
Es reicht, wenn du dir ein LoRa-Modul kaufst, machst eine Antenne dran
und dann irgendeinen Controller und die können miteinander reden.
Also wenn du zwei Controller hast mit zwei LoRa-Modulen,
die können miteinander reden. Du brauchst kein Gateway.
Oder so. Das ist dann halt P2P.
Ja, wenn du ein Gateway hast,
um TNN zu machen, dann ist es was anderes.
Dann kannst du nämlich dein LoRa-Gerät vielleicht auch
außerhalb der Reichweite deines eigenen Empfängers betreiben
und andere Gateways bekommen das dann und schicken es zu dir.
Was? Du hast letztens was für den...
Eine Erweiterung für meinen Ikea-Luftsensor.
Nee, das ist was anderes.
Das ist was anderes, das hat mit dem Ikea-Ding nichts zu tun.
Das ist irgendeine eigene Entwicklung, oder?
Nee, das ist dann...
Ah, nee.
Der funktioniert übrigens wunderbar, mein Ikea-Luftqualitätssensor.
Der steht jetzt hier oben auf dem Schrank und ist aktuell noch grün.
Wollen wir mal kurz reingucken, was der sagt.
Moment, Leute, ich poste euch das mal kurz.
Kein Staub. Hier, so sieht es bei mir gerade im Office aus.
So sieht es bei mir im Office aus.
Da, guckt.
Also, wir haben 24,3 Grad.
41% Luftfeuchtigkeit.
17 Mikrogramm pro Kubikmeter Feinstaub und kein Gas.
180 Gas ist gut.
180 ist kein Gas.
Hoher Wert gut, niedriger Wert schlecht.
Gibt es eine Seite?
Nö.
Außer das Stream-Archiv gibt es nicht.
So.
Äh, pff.
Wir haben uns letzte Woche das Video von ihm dazu angeguckt.
Ähm, ja, was sage ich dazu?
So schnell kann es gehen im Endeffekt.
Es ist eigentlich immer die Abwägung zwischen Bequemlichkeit und Sicherheit.
Und ich glaube, keiner kommt lange, das kann im Prinzip jedem von uns passieren.
Warum wird man von MSI geblockt? Das wüsste ich auch gern.
Ähm, das kann im Prinzip jedem von uns passieren, dass man sich unglücklicher,
gerade wenn man Windows verwendet, dass man sich unglücklicherweise mal irgendeinen Keylogger oder noch schlimmer,
irgendwas, was sich Rootkit-mäßig einlistet und gar Rechner fernsteuern kann, äh, einfängt und dann ist es vorbei.
Weil niemand kommt lange mit einem Browser klar, der beim Löschen quasi alles wegschmei-, äh, beim Schließen alles löscht
und wegschmeißt, wenn man sich jedes Mal neu einloggen muss.
Das hält, das macht keiner lange.
Letztendlich ist es die übliche, das ist die alte Geschichte zwischen Security und Bequemlichkeit.
Und das ist eine Sache, das kann potenziell jedem von uns passieren.
Man kann natürlich seine.
Was heißt das? Seine Angriffs, äh, Oberfläche oder wie man das nennen mag, reduzieren, ja?
Wenn man zum Beispiel, ähm, eine Linux-VM verwendet, wenn man auf irgendwelche shady Seiten gehen möchte oder so.
Das kann man schon machen, aber im Prinzip kann das theoretisch jedem von uns passieren.
Ja, gut. Zwei Monitore, zweimal PC, geschlossene Tür, das wird halt warm.
Michael Fünfspilian, moin, auch wieder am Start.
Tja, das wüsste ich auch gern, warum MSI mich geblockt hat.
Ich weiß es nicht.
Arch, by the way.
Ja, bringt dir aber halt nix.
Wenn du irgendwas hast, was dein Rechner fernsteuern kann oder deine Sessions abgreift oder im Zweifelsfall deinen Keypass aus dem RAM auslesen kann.
Wenn du jetzt das Falsche eingefangen hast, hast du halt gelitten.
Doch, ich hab ne Klimaanlage.
Ne, kann ich nicht.
Ich hab einmal drüben nen ISO-Monitor, den hab ich schon zehn Jahre oder länger.
Ähm, und auf dem Hauptrechner hier hab ich nen BenQ-Monitor mit 240, äh...
Herz.
Die kann ich aber beide nicht großartig für Homeoffice empfehlen.
Also jetzt explizit für Homeoffice.
Kann man natürlich auch für Homeoffice verwenden, sind aber eigentlich zu teuer dafür.
Du kannst jedes x-beliebige Linux verwenden.
Nimm, wenn du dich nicht gut damit auskennst, nimm Linux Mint oder Ubuntu.
Aber Linux Mint ist die bisschen schönere Variante, denk ich, für Leute, die es einfach nur benutzen wollen.
Linux Mint, VM, druff, gib ihm.
Nimm lieber XFCE, weil das ein bisschen schneller ist.
Weil das immer schneller in der VM läuft, weil Gnome und KDE mögen ganz gerne 3D- bzw. 2D-Beschleunigung, was in der VM nicht richtig funktioniert.
Oder mach's wie ich, nimm i3, aber da kommt man als Einsteiger eher schlecht mit klar, wenn man Windows gewohnt ist, glaub ich.
Und fertig, Linux Mint, drauf, gut ist.
Das ist zwar nicht leichtgewichtig, aber leichtgewichtig genug.
RAM hat man heute. RAM ist doch das einzig günstige heute.
Ich mein, ich muss mit meinen 32, ich geh doch irgendwo hin.
RAM ist das einzig günstige heutzutage.
Oder das günstigste von dem, wenn man sich heute einen Rechner kaufen will.
Grafikkarten sind teuer as fuck, CPUs sind teuer as fuck, Mainboards sind teuer as fuck, Gehäuse, alles.
Aber RAM geht. RAM geht. RAM ist das einzige, was halbwegs geht.
Es ist nicht billig, es war schon billiger, aber es geht noch halbwegs.
Der Preis-Champ, den gibt's nicht mehr.
Da war mir das Pflegen der Crawler zu aufwendig.
Ja, aber das macht keiner wirklich.
Das ist halt, das ist, was du sagst, ist im Prinzip Sicherheit versus Bequemlichkeit.
Das drehst du ja durch bei.
Du kannst doch einfach alles in der Linux-VM machen.
Da hast du auch schlechtere Chancen, also bessere Chancen, dir nichts einzufangen.
Ähm, da kannst du dann einige Sachen vielleicht nicht drauf machen, die du machen willst.
Also halt, wie wär's mit dem Weep-Linux?
Das Weep-Linux ist ein Ubuntu mit nem Custom-Skin.
Du meinst das hier, gell?
Sekunde. Du meinst die Qt-VM.
Du meinst das hier.
Leute, macht euch auf was gefasst.
Weeps in. So.
Das sind jetzt die 15 Sekunden für alle Weeps.
Danach mach ich die VM wieder aus.
Okay, fertig.
Genug.
Alles klar.
So, können wir uns YouTube-technisch noch irgendwas angucken?
My crazy new storage server.
Boah, 23 Minuten ist mir jetzt aber echt ein bisschen lang.
Warum diese ab...
Weil man menschliches Gehirn nimmt.
Nee.
Creative Smart Home Ideas 3D printed.
Okay, das können wir uns angucken.
Das sind nur 7 Minuten 57.
Das ist gut.
Zeig mal her.
A 3D printer can unlock endless new possibilities for your smart home.
Und...
Freifad-Akara-Sensor.
Das ist der Standard-Akara-Tür-Tür-Fenster-Kontakt-Sensor.
Aber warum hochkant?
Freifad-Time. Keine Ahnung.
And what surprised me is that 3D printing is actually pretty easy now.
I've been printing some things for my smart home...
Guckst du hin und wieder Surf the Home, ja?
Ich war früher schon die Seite verfolgt, bevor den YouTube-Channel hatten.
Was, wurdest du auf YouTube auch schon mal zensuriert?
Ob Videos von mir schon geploggt wurden?
Ja, erst letztens.
Ich hab letztens ein Video hochgeladen.
Da hab ich zu oft das Wort X-Hamster gesagt.
Ich hab zu oft das Wort X-Hamster gesagt.
Und ich musste das Video dann fünfmal neu hochladen, bis es funktioniert hat.
Und mittlerweile ist das Video allerdings nur ohne Werbung wieder schaubar.
Ich hab leider zu oft X-Hamster gesagt.
Und ich hatte sogar X-Hamster im Titel.
Das war nicht... Das geht nicht. Das ist gleich Block.
Okay, jetzt gucken wir uns das mal an.
...but some of this stuff looks amazing.
I used to think that 3D printers were not that useful.
And I would just end up making toys for my kids.
Okay, yeah, so I've made some toys for my kids.
Wo ist die Standard-I3-Eule? Die seh ich hier nicht.
Wo ist die Eule, die jeder schon mal ausgedruckt hat?
Wisst ihr, was ich mein?
Das Standardmodel, was bei jedem I3-Drucker dabei ist, diese Eule?
I've made some toys for my kids. It's been a lot of fun.
But they have this website called Thingiverse.
Das Benji-Shift, genau.
Like this cord organizer holder thing. Download the file, print it.
And it cost me around 10 cents to make.
Hmm. Ich überleg grade, wozu bräuchte man sowas?
Ich hab zwar hier jede Menge USB-Kabel liegen, aber die meisten stecken in Geräten drinne.
Ich wüsste jetzt grade nicht, was ich damit machen sollte.
Doch! Ich weiß, wofür ich das brauch!
Das ist gar nicht schlecht! Handy! Richtig!
Das ist genau das, was mir auch grade aufgefallen ist. Handy-Aufladestecker.
Das ist gar nicht schlecht. Ich glaube, sowas druck ich mir nachher aus.
Too big and the cord slipped through your hands.
Too big and the cord slipped through.
I can just shrink the sides before printing and it's perfect.
Or this battering. Not only does it look awesome, but it's sharp
and you could probably use it as a home defense weapon.
Oh, cringe joke, alter! Ultra cringiger Witz wieder.
Der Typ ist teilweise echt Pains Champ.
They even have designs for smart home devices on there.
But it's not overflowing with smart home designs.
That was one of my initial concerns in buying a 3D printer.
That was until my friend Ethan showed me how I can build my own designs.
And it's pretty easy.
So you get a caliper like this, which is only around 20 bucks.
So ein Teil hab ich auch.
Leider, leider war ich doof und hab mir ein elektronisches gekauft.
Die Batterie von den Dingern ist so schnell leer, dass es useless as fuck.
It's not too expensive.
Ich mein, man kann es trotzdem ablesen.
Man kann es trotzdem hier ablesen.
Aber ich hätte mir was anderes kaufen sollen.
...and you can measure the exact size of smart home devices
or just things around your house.
So then you can just open up something like Fusion 360
and model your own designs using the measurements from the caliper
and then print it, which is just incredible.
I love doing this and I've been building so many things,
including this mic clip that I'm wearing right now,
which is way better than the mic.
Ich hab, ich hab nen Mic, ich hab nen Mic-Clip, ähm, mit so ner Klammer dran.
Das funktioniert eigentlich ganz gut.
Da wär ich nie auf die Idee gekommen, mir da einen zu, zu drucken mit 3D-Drucker.
Aber aktuell brauch ich den nicht, weil ich es jetzt halt auf hab.
Doch, doch, du kannst die Batterie wechseln.
Aber ich hab keinen Bock drauf, immer wenn ich's brauche,
dann die Batterie zu wechseln.
...Clip it came with.
So now that you know you can download and build your own designs,
let me show you some smart home ideas.
The first thing is this little contact sensor holder
that goes in your garage.
And what's cool about this is that when you attach both contact sensors on here
and you attach it to your garage,
when the garage door opens, the little things swivel
Ah!
Das ist ne richtig gute Idee.
Es gibt normalerweise so Lagesensoren für Garagentore und sowas,
aber das, finde ich, ist ne wirklich gute Idee.
Da kann man nämlich eine 0810
oder 0815 Fenster-Kontakt- oder Tür-Kontakt-Sensor verwenden
für das Garagetor.
Das, finde ich, ist wirklich ne gute Idee.
...your garage door is open or closed.
So you could get something like the multi-purpose sensor from SmartThings,
but that thing is a little bit more money than an inexpensive contact sensor.
Das ist gut. Das ist ne richtig gute Idee.
What's cool about this is that any contact sensor could fit on this design.
Das muss dann aber außen an das Tor.
Nee, warum? Kannst du innen ans Tor pappen?
Innen ans Tor?
Und wenn das Tor hoch geht, dann schwingt das runter.
Ist sogar sinnvoll, innen ans Tor zu machen.
Wobei, es geht in beide Richtungen.
Ja, ich würde das hier mit der Unterseite dranhängen.
Das geht. Kannst du innen ans Tor machen?
Was, wenn du das innen dranmachst, fällt das Teil auf das Tor?
Hä?
Moment, Moment.
Also, wenn ich ein Garagentor hab,
wenn ich ein Garagentor hab,
und das Garagentor, das geht dann meistens irgendwie so auf.
Also die Garage ist hier so.
Hier ist der Ausgang von der Garage.
Und dann mach ich das hier innen dran.
Wo ist denn das Problem?
Der Sensor würde da jetzt quasi so irgendwie dranhängen.
Und dann hier quasi runterhängen.
Und wenn ich das Tor zumache, dann ist das Tor so.
Ups.
Wenn ich das zumache, dann ist das Tor so.
Und, ups.
Alter, Paint, Mann.
So schlecht.
Ne, das ist innen.
So, und wenn ich das zumache, dann ist der...
Ich krieg Anfälle, Paint. Hör mal auf.
So, und wenn ich das zumache, dann ist der Sensor...
Wieso da?
Backweight, wie auch immer.
Ich find die Idee aber gut.
Ich versteh die Zeichnung nicht.
Wie kann man die Zeichnung nicht verstehen mit meinen krassen Paint-Skills?
Das versteh ich nicht.
Cringe, wer die Zeichnung nicht versteht.
I actually made this one.
There's some ones on Thingiverse,
but I like this hinge a little bit better,
because I can just print the whole thing
without needing to assemble it or anything like that.
People will also use these as switches,
so you can put a contact sensor on here
and then design it in a way that's easy to flip on and off
or lights or automations.
And there's this Etsy shop that sells these things,
it's Idea Extruder, and I'll link it down in the description.
So if you're not planning on buying it...
Das ist aber ein stolzer Preis für ein 3D-gedrucktes kleines Teil hier.
Sieben... oder das geht... fünf...
Aber gut, ich mein, es muss sich irgendwie lohnen letztendlich, ja?
Und es lohnt sich nicht,
es knapp über Selbstkostenpreis Leuten zu verkaufen, ist schon klar.
So if you're not planning on buying a 3D-Printer,
there's some things you can get that are really inexpensive but useful.
Alright, this next thing is a motion sensor holder.
And if you look at this, you might be like,
Reid, that thing is just a box.
And you're right, it is a box,
but it's the exact dimensions for this motion sensor.
Äh... aber warum kann ich den Motion Sensor nicht verkaufen?
Kann ich einfach so hinstellen?
Oder warum kann ich, wenn ich ihn an die Wand machen will,
nicht einfach den Motion Sensor an die Wand kleben,
anstatt die Box an die...
Hä? Hä? Versteh ich nicht.
Hab ich nicht kapiert.
I made it so that I can attach it to my nightstand,
and that I can angle it so it only sees my feet
to turn on the light strips at night.
And I've put a motion sensor...
Ja, aber der kann das doch auch so?
Der kann dran pappen, oder? Versteh ich das jetzt nicht.
Oder schraubt er diese...
Der schraubt diese Box da dran und steckt es dann da rein.
Jetzt hab ich glaub ich...
Weil mit ein bisschen Heißkleber
würde das auch mit dem Sensor so funktionieren.
Der...
Ja, stimmt, dazu kann er es einfach rausnehmen, ja.
...my nightstand before,
but sometimes it was just the wrong angle...
Okay, ist doch gar nicht so schlecht.
...and this is just gonna make it way easier to mount...
Ja, versteh ich, okay.
...and be able to change the batteries whenever they die.
Das leuchtet mir ein.
...pretty simple, but super useful.
Alright, this next thing is also for my nightstand,
because I feel like my nightstand
is always getting cluttered with stuff.
So I wanted to move the Echo Dot off...
By the way, das ist der Kerl,
der daheim irgendwie sieben verschiedene Fernsehs hat
und 85 verschiedene Apps auf seinem Smartphone braucht,
um sein Smart Home bedienen zu können.
...a little bit.
So I made this little mount,
holder, floating holder thing,
and you can put the Echo Dot on there
and it just clamps on to the back of my nightstand.
And it works pretty well, actually,
but I do need to make some tweaks to it
to make it stronger,
maybe change the design a little bit for that.
So, still a work in progress, but...
Was genau ist der Vorteil davon,
anstatt dass er seinen Echo einfach auf den Schreibtisch stellt?
Das habe ich diesmal nicht kapiert.
...but so far, it works pretty well.
Es sieht fancy aus.
There's also tons of smart speaker mount designs
that you can download and print.
...on your outlet, on the pegboard...
Aber das ist eh nicht das Richtige für mich.
Bei mir kommt weder Siri noch Alexa noch Google Home
oder sonst was ins Haus.
Platz auf dem Tisch?
Dafür war...
Also wenn das nicht genug Platz auf dem Tisch ist,
dann will der meinen Tisch nicht sehen.
...make some cool things like an R2D2 holder.
If you have a ledge in your house,
you can print a ramp for your robot vacuum.
You can even print mounts for your video doorbell,
so you can angle it better,
90 degrees.
And I know that they have these on Amazon,
but it might not fit your doorbell
or be exactly how you want it.
For example, dashboard mounts.
I bought this on Amazon and...
Diese 3D-gedruckten Sachen sind erstaunlich widerstandsfähig.
Also gerade, wenn man auch die Möglichkeit hat,
hier außen dann sowas mit Infill zu drucken oder so,
das ist wirklich echt stabil.
Also wenn du...
Also ich würde mal behaupten,
wenn ich...
Keine Ahnung, ich würde wirklich mit ordentlich Infill
zwei Sachen drucken,
die ich bei mir an die Treppe dran klipsen könnte von unten,
da könnte ich mich da ohne Probleme dranhängen.
Das würde das aushalten.
Ja, für Outdoor ist das nicht unbedingt gut.
Das stimmt.
Wobei ich selbst da sagen würde,
zum größten Teil sollte das ja...
Sollte das eigentlich eine Weile halten.
Aber was ich meine, es ist...
Also es hält viel aus, belastungstechnisch.
Das hätte ich am Anfang nicht gedacht.
Es kann natürlich auch manchmal Painschamp werden,
wenn man was ausgedruckt hat mit zu viel Support und Infill-Zeug
und man braucht es nicht und muss es dann rauskratzen.
Aber ansonsten ist das wirklich viel stabiler,
als ich das ursprünglich gedacht hätte.
Hey, but there's definitely ways I can improve it
or make one for a different tablet
that I want to use.
So 3D-Printing is super useful.
Now, this next thing is my favorite thing.
And if you remember in my old videos,
I used to have this little cloud light from SwitchBot.
And people would ask all the time about it,
because they wanted a cool little light
that they could use for notifications.
So when I came across this cube on Thingiverse,
I was like, I need to make this smart.
Okay, Paul, kind man.
And they made it so that you could put some light strips in there.
So of course I used some smart light strips.
And for the diffusion material,
I'm actually using white filament.
And I measured squares.
Das ist übrigens was, was ich mir auch schon öfters überlegt habe.
Wenn man nur ein paar LEDs braucht,
man kann ja die LED-Strips auseinander schneiden.
Die funktionieren wunderbar.
Also du kannst aus so einem LED-Strip,
der einen Meter lang ist, kannst du ohne Probleme
ein paar Zentimeter lange Häppchen machen.
Also die funktionieren komplett unabhängig voneinander,
die LEDs.
Da muss man sich nicht extra was kaufen.
Printed it at half a millimeter thick,
which was plenty to let out enough light.
And not only does this thing look awesome,
but it's also really useful.
Ich weiß nicht.
I can use it for notifications,
changing the different light colors.
Okay, das ist eine gute Idee.
Das ist eine gute Idee, aber ganz ehrlich,
entweder sitze ich hier vorm PC
oder ich habe mein Handy irgendwie dabei
und sonst wie was.
Notifications kriege ich auch so.
Also ich kriege die meisten Notifications eh aufs Handy.
Ähm.
Also keine Ahnung, wenn das Hoftor aufgeht zum Beispiel
und so was.
Das ist nice to have.
Also das ist eigentlich für meine Zwecke.
Phone battery is getting low.
Ja, brauche ich nicht.
I can have it change to yellow.
If a package was left at the door,
it can flash orange.
Or if I need to start wrapping up work
and get ready for dinner,
then it can change to red.
Machst du die Notifications über die Home Assistant App?
Die haben auch Apple Push Notifications,
gehen damit auch.
I love that the light is not too bright or distracting,
but it still looks incredible on the desk.
So if you're thinking about getting a 3D printer,
I recently bought this Ender 3 S1.
And I've loved it, because it's giving me zero issues.
Das ist doch so der ein-, das ist doch aktuell,
der Ender Drucker, das ist doch so dieser Einsteiger 3D Drucker,
der überall empfohlen wird, ne?
Ähm.
Meiner ist schon ein bisschen älter.
Ich weiß, ich bin da gerade nicht mal im aktuellsten Stand.
Das sind doch so die Einsteiger-Tipps schlechthin.
And everything just works out of the box.
A lot of people would buy the Ender 3s
and upgrade a lot of the parts.
And this comes with pretty much all that stuff.
Nutzt du Android oder iOS für dein Smart Home?
Äh, weder noch.
Mein Smart Home läuft auf, äh,
in der Linux-Kiste in der VM.
Ähm, also läuft auf Linux-Basis.
Endgerät ist eine Mischung.
Ich hab sowohl Android-Endgeräte als auch iOS-Endgeräte,
also mobile Sachen und Autoschild-TV und sowas,
alles, alles Mögliche dabei.
Weder noch, also ich hab nichts
laufen auf iOS oder auf Android,
was jetzt die Heimautomatisierung selber machen würde.
Ich hab nur Endgeräte.
... an automatic bed leveler.
So, you plug it in and it just works.
I'm planning on adding a raspberry pipe to this USB-C port.
Automatisches Bed Leveling hätte ich auch gerne
bei meinem 3D-Drucker,
beziehungsweise dass er sich das misst und einstellt.
Was ein Akt das war, unten an diesen Rädchen
das alles richtig einzustellen, das war eklig.
... Octa-Print, so I can connect it to Home Assistant
and have it connected to my Smart Home
when prints are done and have prints automatically sent to it.
I'm also using a Eufy Pan & Tilt Cam back here
to keep an eye on the print so I can check it remotely.
And I also got this table slash desk on Amazon
and you'd be surprised at how difficult it is to find
an inexpensive desk that's also sturdy for a 3D-Printer.
I'll link that, the film and stuff...
Wie oft man schon das Bett levelt, ich hab das...
Naja, ich hab's einmal scheiße gelevelt,
aber richtig mega kacke gelevelt.
Da sind die Sachen nicht hängen geblieben.
Das war aber, als ich den neu hatte, da hatte ich keine Ahnung von.
Und dann hab ich irgendwann mich mal zwei, drei Stunden hingesetzt,
das ordentlich gelevelt mit Testdrucken.
Und seitdem...
Seitdem ist es eigentlich gelevelt, ja.
Auf der anderen Seite muss man aber sagen,
ich könnte mir schon vorstellen, dass das sich mit der Zeit
ein bisschen verzieht oder keine Ahnung, weiß ich gar nicht.
Dass es mit der Zeit vielleicht ein bisschen elastischer wird oder so.
Und deswegen finde ich ja dieses Automatische,
was beispielsweise diese Prusa-Printer haben,
also diese, wo du 1.000 Euro plus pro Drucker bezahlst,
finde ich halt sehr nice, dass die dann automatisch auch noch
am Anfang gucken und so ein Profil erstellen für Unebenheiten und sowas.
Das ist richtig, richtig nice.
Aber da musstet ihr halt erst mal 1.000 Euro 3D-Drucker kaufen.
Schon mal von Resin-3D-Printer gehört.
Ja, das ist cool für Leute, die, keine Ahnung,
Warhammer-Figuren drucken wollen oder sowas.
Ein Kollege von mir auf der Arbeit, der steht richtig auf so Warhammer-Sachen
zum Selbstbemalen und sowas.
Für den ist ein Resin, Resin, Resin, wie haben wir das?
Tarts heißt das, glaube ich, auf Deutsch.
3D-Drucker natürlich POG.
...I'm using everything down in the description.
If you guys have any questions about 3D-Printing
or have some suggestions on things to make,
then let me know down in the comments.
Thanks for watching.
Wie, das war's schon?
Da war jetzt aber nicht so viel dabei.
Aber trotzdem, nice, nice vid.
So, was empfiehlt uns YouTube denn noch?
Erkenntnisse aus meinem smarten Garten.
Kann nicht alles klappen.
Daraus lernt man ja auch was.
Okay, können wir uns noch irgendwas angucken?
Was haben wir noch zu bieten?
Storage?
Building a card-shooting Lego-Tank.
19 Minuten, nein.
Das Nein, das Direct-Video habe ich noch nicht geguckt.
Das ist aber auch zu lang.
Leute, ich bin jetzt 3 Stunden und ich gehe jetzt was essen.
Ich gehe jetzt was essen und vielleicht,
vielleicht machen wir heute Abend den Label-Champ weiter
oder irgendwas anderes.
Kann man auch bei einem, Moment, was?
Kann man auch bei einem günstigen Drucker auch nachrestaurieren?
Ja, ich wollte gar nicht so viel an dem 3D-Drucker rumbasteln.
Ich verwende meinen 3D-Drucker eh nicht so oft.
Ich habe mir das viel, viel nützlicher vorgestellt.
Also, ich dachte ja, als ich mir den 3D-Drucker gekauft habe,
nach dem Motto, ich drücke da wöchentlich mehrere Sachen aus.
Letztendlich ist es so, dass ich vielleicht alle zwei Wochen
mal was Kleines drucke.
Pipo fett.
Danke, Leute, ja.
Wir könnten, wir gehen jetzt einfach alle, Chat,
alle was futtern zusammen.
Also, jeder für sich, aber geistig mit dem Chat.
Gehen wir jetzt, gehen wir jetzt alle was essen.
Ich glaube, ich hole mir jetzt ein paar Nudeln.
Ich habe noch Nudeln übrig.
Die guten italienischen, teuren Nudeln von diesem,
von diesem italienischen Internet-Shop,
den ich euch schon mal gezeigt habe.
Mamma mia.
Gucken wir mal schnell, ob ich irgendjemanden hosten kann.
Nämlich Follower und der nicht schon so viele Viewer hat,
der das bräuchte.
TC Bounty spielt wieder Battlefield 3.
Der geht immer.
Das finde ich nice, dass das noch gespielt wird.
Den haben wir letztens erst gehostet.
JV Peak ist online, den haben wir aber auch
letztens erst gehostet.
Gut, Leute, egal.
Ich gehe jetzt auf.
Wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal.
Bis dann.
See you!